EVERYONE.
TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE ACOSTA
PROTECTION AND ACCESS TO NATURAL
RESOURCES HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
ATTENDANCE HERE THIS IS THE
FIRST HEARING FOR THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE FOR THE YEAR AND.
HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE A FEW MORE
CONTINUE WHICH THINK TOPICS.
VERY HAPPY TO HAVE OPC HERE AND
THIS.
GREAT SET OF PANELS.
TO TALK ABOUT. YOUR GRASS AND
CAL AND.
HOW WE MANAGE CHANGING OCEAN
CHEMISTRY IS FOR THE BETTER IS
WE ALL KNOW?
THAT EVEN THOUGH ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THEY DON'T SEEM TO
UNDERSTAND.
PROGRESS WE'VE BEEN MAKING WE'RE
GONNA SEE CONTINUING CALIFORNIA
TO MAKE PROGRESS MITIGATING AND
ADAPTING TO THE EFFECTS OF OUR
CHANGING CLIMATE.
AND OCEAN ACIDIFICATION HYPOXIA
THE CHANGING CHEMISTRY IN THE
OCEAN IS CLEARLY.
AT ISSUE FOR CALIFORNIA THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON.
AND.
SUBMERGED AQUATIC VEGETATION FOR
ME IS ALSO VERY INTERESTING
BECAUSE. BACK IN MY DAYS ARE
COASTAL COMMISSION WE ARE CHINA
PROTECTS
AND MANAGE A LOT OF THE EELGRASS
BECAME AN IMPORTANT PART. OF.
PERMIT DISCUSSIONS AROUND
DEVELOPMENT VARIOUS PARTS OF THE
STATE.
AND ONE THINKS IT'S VERY TRUE AS
WE ALL KNOW.
IF YOU WANT HELP OUR ENVIRONMENT
WE GO PLANT A TREE.
DOES NOT WORK THE SAME FOR
SUBMERGED AQUATIC VEGETATION
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO SAY WE'RE
GONNA MITIGATE THE LOSS OF YOUR
GRASS IN ONE PLACE. PLANTED IN
ANOTHER AND EXPECTED SUCCESS IN
FACT A LOT OF THE MEDICATIONS
THAT THE COAST COMMISSION LOOKED
AT OVER THE YEARS WERE
MARGINALLY SUCCESSFUL.
SO EVEN THOUGH THERE WAS A
DEVELOPMENT THAT WAS PERMITTED
BASED ON A CERTAIN.
MITIGATION STRATEGYTHIS
MITIGATION STRATEGIES DO NOT
ALWAYS HAVE.
THE FACTS
AND SO THE MORE WE COULD WORK TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS COURT OF
VEGETATION WORKS.
WHERE IT WORKS AND THOUGH THE
BROADER IMPACTS IT CAN HAVE ON
PROTECTING OUR OCEANS AND OUR
COASTAL RESOURCES I THINK THE
MORE SIGNIFICANT IT ADDS?
AND THE OTHER.
LOGISTICAL REASON OF ARE HAPPY
TO BE DOING THIS HERE TODAY IS I
WOULD LIKE TO DO MORE.
WE SINCE I COME FROM COUNTY AWAY
AND WHERE THE ADMINISTRATION THE
EXECUTIVE IN THE JUDICIAL ARE
ALSO OF TIED TOGETHER.
THAT
THREE SEPARATE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT DON'T ALWAYS WORK
THAT WELL TOGETHER AND OSHA
PRODUCTION TAP COUNSEL DOES A
VERY GOOD JOB A LOT OF THE STATE
AGENCIES A VERY GOOD JOB
REPORTING TO.
THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT WHAT
SOME THE CHALLENGES ARE.
BUT I WANTED TO BRING THESE
CONVERSATIONS INTO THE
LEGISLATURE SO THAT WE CAN BE A
PART OF SOME OF THE IDEAS THE
POLICY CHANGES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING ON.
AND UNDERSTAND REALLY HOW TO BE
YOUR PARTNERS.
IN WORKING IN ASSURING WERE
WORKING STRATEGIES TO BETTER
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENT TO
ADAPTS TO MITIGATE TO MANAGE AS
WE MOVE FORWARD. AND IF
ANYBODY'S BEEN INVOLVED IN
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS YOU KNOW
THAT MEMBERS TO COME AND GO.
THIS IS BEING WEB CAST IT'S
BEING TELEVISED IT'S IT'S
AVAILABLE SO WE ARE CREATING A
VERY A PORTENT LEGISLATIVE
RECORD HERE TODAY.
SO EVEN IF WE DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF FOLKS SHOWING UP WHERE THE
SHOPS RADICALLY BASED ON
SCHEDULES THIS IS STILL AN
IMPORTANT PART OF HOW WE CONDUCT
OUR BUSINESS.
AND I KNOW LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES
ARE INTERESTED IN POLICY
MEASURES.
LOOKING FOR PRODUCTIVE WAYS THAT
WE CAN IN OUR LEGISLATIVE
CONTACTS
BE OF ASSISTANCE IN.
THAT MITIGATION AND ADAPTATION
QUESTIONS AND THAT'S WHY DOING
THIS AND SAID CONTEXT I THINK IS
SO IMPORTANT.
SO LET'S START WITH THE HEARING.
WE HAVE.
A COUPLE DIFFERENT PANELS WERE
GONNA GO TO THE FIRST PANEL IS
STATE PERSPECTIVES AND WE HAVE
CALIFORNIA. SECRETARY NATURAL
RESOURCES JOHN THERE'D HERE CHEN
ALWAYS VERY HAPPY TO HAVE YOU
COME PRESENT BACK IN THE
LEGISLATURE'S YOU HAD DONE FOR
SO MANY YEARS.
THEN DEBORAH HOPPER SAID WHO'S
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL.
VERY SMALL CHIEF DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE STATE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY.
AND THEY WERE GONNA HEAR FROM
THE OPC SCIENCE ADVISORY TEAM
CREATED NIELSEN FROM TARA
FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY AND
JAY STOCK WAS FROM UC DAVIS.
TALKING A BIT MORE IN
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE RESEARCH
THAT HAS BEEN DONE.
BRINGING THE SCIENCE PERSPECTIVE
IN THE POLICY IS HAS ALWAYS BEEN
A PORN BUT NOW IT'S INCREASINGLY
IMPORTANT.
ESPECIALLY WITH A LOT OF THE
RECENT DENIALS OF THE VALUE OF
SCIENCE IN POLICY MAKING.
WE ARE GOING TO USE IT TO THE
BEST EXTENT WE CAN THAT'S WHAT
THIS HEARING IS ABOUT SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO IT.
SECRETARY LEAD GOING TO LEAD US
OFF THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APOLOGIZE BECAUSE I CAN ONLY
STAY FOR ABOUT THE FIRST HALF
HOUR STEERING BUT.
A I WAS AMUSED WHEN YOU SAID IT
MAY HEARING LEGISLATORS COME AND
GO THAT'S ALSO TRUE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
I HAD A MUCH DELAYED POST MATIC
STRESS BY COMING TO THIS ROOM A
OF. A GIVEN SOME OF THEM WANT
THE HEARINGS THAT.
THAT I EXPERIENCED IN HERE. BAR
I WANT TO TAKE MY BRIEF TIME TO
MAYBE SET THE CONTEXT OF FOR
THIS HEARING. AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING IT BECAUSE IT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND ONE WHERE
THE LIGHT NEEDS TO BE SHOWN.
EVEN WHEN.
THIS ADMINISTRATION TEN MEN.
WE WERE NOT REALLY DOING MUCH ON
THE ISSUE OF OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
AND AND TRYING TO TAKE A
STRATEGIC PLAN THAT HAD JUST
BEEN ADOPTED THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL AND GIVE IT
PRIORITIES.
ONE OF THE FOUR PRIORITIES.
HOW I REALLY GOT EVERYBODY TO
MOVE WITH WAS TO TRY TO ATTACK
THE ISSUE OF OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION?
AND IN DOING IT IN AND TWENTY
THIRTEEN.
I CONVENED.
A PANEL A SCIENTIFIC PANEL BUT
TO DEAL WITH THIS
AND HAS A WASHINGTON AND OREGON.
WERE HAVING VERY SIMILAR ISSUES.
AND PARTICULARLY WASHINGTON WITH
WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH THEIR
SHELLFISH INDUSTRY IN PUGET
SOUND. IT WAS A MATTER OF TIME
BEFORE THE EFFORT MERGED.
INTO A THREE STATE EFFORT
AND IT LED TO A STUDY.
THAT JUNE WAS DONE AND RELEASED
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. AND IT WAS A
VERY UNIQUE STUDY BECAUSE MANY
TIMES.
YOU LOOK AT THE SCIENCE AND USE.
HERE'S THE SCIENCE OF WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION BUT YOU DON'T
NECESSARILY GET ATTACHED TO IT
WHAT EARLY ACTIONS ARE THAT YOU
CAN TAKE.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS STUDY DID
AND THERE ARE PEOPLE HERE.
THAT WORKED ON THAT THAT ARE
GOING TO CONFORM YOU AND. AS A
LAY PERSON THAT WERE ALL INDS
OF THINGS IN THERE WHERE I HAD
REALLY YOU.
TRY TO HARDEN THE SHELLS OF SOME
OF THE SHELLFISH THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS YOU DO. BUT THERE
WERE.
MANY DIFFERENT ACTIONS AND THEN
WE WENT TO THE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL.
ANNA APPROPRIATED SOME REMAINING
BOND TO HOLLERS FOR ABOUT THREE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
PART OF.
SORT OF WORK TO DO SOME OF ARE
PART OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE STUDY AND THE ACTIONS.
AND.
THAT LEGISLATURE ALSO PASSED
TWO BILLS
OUR THANKS TO A TO A STRONG
PUBLIC SUPPORT.
AND WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE.
TO DO THE ADVISORY TEAM AND
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
MANDATED BY THOSE BILLS.
BUT IN THE OVERVIEW I THINK THE
THING THAT WAS IMPORTANT TO ME.
IS THAT AS THE ADMINISTRATION IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LEGISLATURE
HAS MOVED THROUGH CAP AND TRADE.
ROOM CAP AND TRADE IN MANY WAYS.
AND HAS NOT INTERSECTED WITH THE
OCEAN.
OF BECAUSE THERE REALLY INTO IT
TO TWO REALLY JUSTIFY IT IN THE
FIRST ITERATION OF CAP AND TRADE
MEET THE TIGHTEST OF LEGAL TESS.
YOU HAD TO HAVE DEMONSTRATED
SCIENCE.
THAT SHOWED THAT YOU WERE
CAPTURING CARBON YOU COULD
QUANTIFY AVOID PROVE IT.
AND IN MANY WHY SOME OF THE
STUDIES THAT WE HAVE AHA
EMBARKED ON. WITH THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL MONEY.
IS TO DEMONSTRATE THAT AND HAVE
THE SCIENTIFIC BASIS THAT IF IN
FUTURE ROUNDS WE THINK THAT
THERE IS CARBON CAPTURE TO BE
MADE BY THE VERY SUBJECT OF THIS
HEARING. THAN WE HAVE LAID THE
SCIENTIFIC BASIS
TO DO IT.
AND I THINK THE CHALLENGES AND.
THE CHAIRMAN AS A MEMBER OF THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL AND HE
HEARD ME GIFT THIS LITTLE RIFF
AT THE MEETING LAST WEEK.
THE CHALLENGES IS THE PERFECT
WORLD OF SCIENCE
THAT'S NOT ALWAYS INTERSECT
WITH GOVERNMENT JOB LINES OF
POLITICAL REALITIES.
AND SO YES WE WANT IT PEER
REVIEW AND YES WE WANT BELLS AND
WHISTLES TO PROVE IT EXACTLY.
BUT THE OCEANS DETERIORATING
ADMINISTRATIONS ARE CHANGING.
HOW WE HAVE THE POLITICAL WILL
AND THE ABILITY TO DO IT AND WE
WOULD LIKE
TO INTERSECT THE TO IN ITS AYE
PLENTIFULLY SAID AT THE MEETING
THE OTHER DAY WE WOULD LIKE IT
TO THE SCIENCE DONE SOMETIME IN
THE COURSE OF OUR NATURAL LIFE?
AND AND SO BAD IT'S OUR
CHALLENGE INNER IT IS DOING THAT
AND. WE ALSO HAVE THE CHALLENGE
YOU ALLUDED TO WHICH IS OUR
WHAT'S GOING ON ARE NOT GOING ON
AT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RIGHT
NOW.
AND SO. WITH THE RELATIONSHIPS
WE BUILT.
WITH WASHINGTON AND OREGON.
WE LAUNCHED THE INTERNATIONAL
ALLIANCE TO FIGHT OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION.
ALONG THE LINES.
OF THE PARIS CLIMATE COURTS
WHERE WE GET INDIVIDUAL NATIONS.
OR.
.
SUB STATES TO COME IN AND MAKE
THEIR OWN INDIVIDUAL COMMITMENTS
ON WHAT THEYWILL DO AND AGREED
TO MAKE THOSE COMMITMENTS ON THE
CERTIFICATION AND. THE EARLY
INITIATORS ON IT WAS LAUNCHED BY
OUR GOVERNOR IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OF WASHINGTON AND OREGON. รณ WE
HAD FRANCE AND CHILE JOIN US. IT
CENTS BENT ICELAND THE AMORITES
FIJI'S AND I KEEP SAYING
COUNTRIES IN THE PACIFIC THAT
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF BEFORE. BUT
IT IS BROADENING.
AND IT IS TRYING TO TAKE THAT
COMMITMENT AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
WE DO IT. AND SO THERE ARE GREAT
THING ABOUT THIS HEARING.
IS IT EDUCATES THE LEGISLATORS
ABOUT HOW THIS IS ONE
OPPORTUNITY OVER TIME TO DO IT.
AND YOU CAN HELP US WITH THAT
KIND OF PRESSURE.
KEEP MOVING.
AND RIGHT NOW I'M LOOKING AT
THREE LEGISLATOR STEP WILL BE
HERE. FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
AFTER I'M SECRETARY AND. THAT IS
DONE AND SO I AM HOPING FAT.
THAT KIND OF INSTITUTIONAL PUSH
WILL RESIDE ITSELF WITH YOU. AND
THINGS THAT WE HAVE STARTED IT
MIGHT THE GROUNDWORK FOR TO DEAL
WITH CAP AND TRADE INTERNATIONAL
CONNECTIONS TO EDUCATION ON THE
SCIENCE.
AND MOVING EVERYBODY ALONG WILL
BE SOMETHING THAT YOU WANT TO
TAKE FORWARD AS WELL SO. THOSE
ARE THE OPENING COMMENTS I WANT
TO MAKE A MINUTE TURN IT OVER TO
DEBRA HOW MUCH THAT IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COMES.
THANK YOU SECRETARY LAIRD AND
CAN THANK YOU CHAIRMAN STONE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
INVITING US HERE TO TALK TODAY
ABOUT AND SEA GRASSES AND
CALVIN.
THE TERM SUBMERGED AQUATIC
VEGETATION.
WHICH REALLY AND.
OUR PRIOR GOAL HERE IS TO BUILD
ON THE MOMENTUM TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND AND AND BE ABLE TO
TAKE ACTION TO.
LESSEN THE IMPACTS OF OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION I'M SICK AND MY
NAME IS DEBORAH HALBERSTADT I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL IS. M..
IS A STATE ENTITY THAT'S
COMMITTED TO AND MAINTAINING
HEALTHY RESILIENT AND PRODUCTIVE
OCEAN AND COASTAL ECOSYSTEMS FOR
THE BENEFIT OF. CURRENT AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS AND WE'RE
REALLY AND COMMITTED TO BASING
OUR DECISIONS ON. BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE AND TO PROMOTING THE USE
OF SCIENCE AND. IN ORDER TO
MANAGE OCEAN ACTIVITIES IN OCEAN
RESEARCHERS REESE RESOURCES AND.
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE SO EXCITED
TODAY TO BE ABLE TO BRING
TOGETHER SCIENTISTS POLICYMAKERS
AND MANAGERS TO TALK ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC.
AND AS SECRETARY LAIRD DESCRIBED
IN DETAIL ARE ARE OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION PROGRAM HAS GROWN
TREMENDOUSLY OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS STEMMING IN LARGE PART
FROM THE RELEASE OF THAT WEST
COAST OCEAN ACIDIFICATION AND
HYPOXIA SCIENCE PANEL. AND.
AND ONE OF THE PANEL'S
RECOMMENDATIONS WAS TO ADVANCE
APPROACHES THAT REMOVE CARBON
DIOXIDE FROM SEA WATER AND
SPECIFICALLY. THEIR
RECOMMENDATION BECAUSE OUT
RESTORATION AND CONSERVATION OF
SUBMERGED AQUATIC VEGETATION
SUCH AS SEA GRASS AND CAL. AS E.
NATURAL STRATEGY TO YOU MEET
THIS GOAL COMBAT AS CHAIRMAN
STONE MENTIONED AND.
THE RESTORATION IS NOT ALWAYS AN
EASY TASK WHEN YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT AND SEAGRASSES.
SO FOLLOWING THE RELEASE OF THE
THE PANEL REPORT AND THE STATE
LEGISLATURE PASSED TWO BILLS.
IMPLEMENTING RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE PANEL. ONE OF THESE BILLS
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE
BECAUSE FOR SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
BASED APPROACHES TO PROTECTING
AND RESTORING SEAGRASS AS A
CRITICAL STRATEGY IN ENHANCING
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO
WITHSTAND. OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
AND SO SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
SIXTY THREE.
I THINK REALLY STARTS TO ADDRESS
CHAIRMAN STONE'S COMMENTS ABOUT
NEEDING TO INCREASE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
EXECUTIVE AND THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCHES SO WE HAD A REPORT THAT
WAS COMMISSIONED BY. THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND THEN TAKING
UP BY THE LEGISLATURE AND NOW
THE LEGISLATURE HAS AND NEED STE
SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS.
REQUIRING THE OPC TO TAKE
CERTAIN ACTIONS IS A REALLY NICE
M. SYNTHESIS
AND AND.
PC.
I AND OUR REALLY RICH NETWORK OF
PARTNERS AND HAVE BEEN MAKING
GREAT PROGRESS IN EACH OF THE
TASKS OUTLINED IN THE BILL SO
THEREFORE. TASKS
NUMBER ONE IS RESEARCHING HOW
EELGRASS FUNCTIONS FOR CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL AND OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION.
MITIGATION AND IF FOR THAT WE
ARE WORKING ON DEVELOPING A
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS
TO RESEARCH HOW IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECOLOGICAL
FACTORS INTERACT ACROSS SPACE
AND TIME. TO INFLUENCE HOW
GEOGRAPHICALLY DISPERSED
EELGRASS BEDS CAN FUNCTION FOR
CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL AND
HYPOXIA REDUCTION. I'M IN TO
THIS POINT OPC FUNDED SEVERAL
INNOVATIVE RESEARCH AND
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS
AND IN THESE PROJECTS.
ARE INTENDED TO HELP US FILL
SOME GAPS IN UNDERSTANDING HOW
NATURAL AND RESTORED SEAGRASS
BEDS CAN HELP AMELIORATE OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION AND UNDERSTANDING
ALSO THE. BUFFERING POTENTIAL OF
SEA GRASS ON OYSTER AQUACULTURE.
I'M SAID TODAY YOU'LL HEAR MORE
DETAILS ABOUT THIS FRIEND DOCTOR
TESTED HILL WHEN OF THE OPC
TIME.
FUNDED SCIENTISTS ON WHO WILL BE
SPEAKING IN THE SECOND PANEL.
AND THE SECOND TASK IS TO
GENERATE AN INVENTORY OF
LOCATIONS WHERE CONSERVATION OR
RESTORATION OF AQUATIC HABITATS
INCLUDING L. GRASS CAN BE
SUCCESSFULLY APPLIED TO
MITIGATE.
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION AND AND
RESULTS FROM OPC FUNDED
PROJECTS.
AND OTHER EFFORTS ARE HELPING TO
BUILD AN INFORMANT'S INVENTORY
AND A WHERE KEY WHERE LOOKING
FOR WAYS TO BUILD OUT THIS
INVENTORY WITH FUTURE PROJECTS.
I THIRD TASK IS TO INCORPORATE
CONSIDERATION OF CARBON DIOXIDE
REMOVAL.
FOR YOUR GRASS RESTORATION
PROJECTS DURING THE HABITAT
RESTORATION PLANNING PROCESS.
AND THE GOAL THERE IS TO YOU
ACCOUNT FOR THE BENEFITS OF LONG
TERM SEQUESTRATION AND. IN
ADDITION TO THE HABITAT
RESTORATION SO THAT'S REALLY
GETTING AT NOT JUST THE. AND.
AWAY NOT NOT JUST THAT
ADAPTATION PART OF. OF.
SEE GAS
BUT ALSO THE MITIGATION
POTENTIAL.
AND.
SO AS SCIENCE ON CARBON STORAGE
BY EELGRASS ADVANCES STATE LED
RESTORATION OF YOUR GRASS WILL
BE ABLE TO REALLY THINK THERE
AND CONSIDER THE BENEFITTED
CARBON STORAGE AS ONE OF THE
MANY CO BENEFITS HAVE. AND
RESTORATION AND MARY SMALL FROM
THE C. COASTAL CONSERVANCY WILL
BE REPORTING ON SOME OF.
AT THE ADVANCES ON THIS FRONT.
AND FINALLY NUMBER FOUR OF OUR
TASKS IS TO SUPPORT SCIENCE
MONITORING COORDINATION TO
ENSURE THAT OCEAN AND COASTAL
POLICY AND MANAGEMENT
CALIFORNIA.
REFLECT THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE ON STRATEGIES
TO REDUCE OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
HYPOXIA SO THIS IS WHERE OPC
ALONG WITH OUR PARTNERS LIKE THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY AND LIKE THE
OCEAN SCIENCE TRUST. LAKE OUR
OPC SAT AND WORK TOGETHER TO
STRENGTHEN OUR COLLABORATION AND
AND REALLY DEVELOP AND SOME KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS AND PROGRESS
THAT CAN COME OUT OF THE
RESEARCH THAT'S HAPPENING.
AND.
SO THESE PROJECTS AND SCIENTIFIC
ADVANCES ARE REALLY CRUCIAL TO
BETTER UNDERSTANDING ALL OF THE
ELEMENTS OF THE LEGISLATION. BUT
WITH AND WITHOUT.
FUNDING FROM THE LEGISLATION WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO UTILIZE STEVE
FUNDS TO IMPLEMENT THE TASKS IN
SB THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE AND VOTE
AS SECRETARY LAIRD MENTIONED
JUST A MOMENT AGO. FUTURE
FUNDING WILL REALLY BE CRITICAL
IN ADVANCING OUR WORK ON THIS
TOPIC.
AND.
EVEN WITH ALL OF THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING IN WITH OUR EMERGING
UNDERSTANDING THERE'S STILL A
LOT THERE'S A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY.
TIME ASSOCIATED WITH USING THESE
HABITATS TO MITIGATE OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION AND YOU'LL HEAR
MORE ABOUT THAT FROM HER OUR
SECOND PANEL. AND WE ARE REALLY
WORKING HARD TO ENSURE THAT THE
BEST SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
MAKE MANAGEMENT DECISIONS.
WHILE BEING BOLD AND WHILE BEING
VISIONARY AND SO FOR EXAMPLE.
WHEN WE DO LEARN ABOUT HOW
HABITATS CAN HELP AMELIORATE
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION THAT WE WANT
TO FOLLOW THAT SCIENTIFIC
KNOWLEDGE WITH PILOT. I
RESTORATION PROJECTS
THAT WE CAN PARTNER WITH THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY ON AND BUILD
ON OUR KNOWLEDGE WHILE REALLY
IMPLEMENTING ON THE GROUND
PROJECTS.
AND.
WE'RE REALLY COMMITTED TO
PROTECTING RESTORING THESE
HABITATS BOTH FOR THE ECOSYSTEM.
BENEFITS THEY PROVIDE AS WELL AS
THE POTENTIAL FOR AND.
A CLIMATE CHANGE READINESS THAT
THEY THAT THEY MAY PROVIDE AND
AND WE WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THESE
PROJECTS
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANNEX I'D
LIKE TO ASK INTRODUCED MARRY
SMALL FROM THE STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY AND SHE CAN SPEAK
MORE. ON THEIR EFFORTS AT THE
CONSERVANCY.
OKAY THANK YOU DEBORAH THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME.
AND.
AND AS AS EVER SAID I'M GONNA
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY'S ROLE IN
THIS WORLD AND PRIMARILY
SUPPORTING PILOT PROJECTS.
PROJECTS THAT TIED TOGETHER.
.
EXPERIMENTAL RESTORATION WITH
SCIENCE AND MONITORING. AND
TRYING TO ADVANCE MULTI BENEFIT
PROJECTS IN THIS CONTEXT.
DOES THIS WORK.
NOW. I GET. SO AND THIS IS A
SCHEMATIC OF JUST SORT OF TRYING
TO. BUILD IN A LITTLE BIT OF
CONTEXT
AND BECAUSE OF AN SEVENTY WERE
REALLY TRYING TO THINK ABOUT
RESTORING MORE COMPLETE HABITAT
SYSTEMS SO I LIKE TO SAY WETLAND
RESTORATION ISN'T JUST WETLANDS
ANYMORE. BUT IT'S LOOKING AT THE
TRANSITIONAL UPLAND IT'S LOOKING
AT THE TRANSITIONAL SUBTITLE
HABITAT AND RESTORING THESE MORE
COMPLETE SYSTEMS BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
ECOLOGICAL INTERACTIONS. THAT
HAPPEN AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT IS
CLIMATE CHANGE.
HAPPENS THERE'S GOING TO BE A.
NEED FOR THAT INTEGRITY ACROSS
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT SUBTITLE
HABITATS
PROVIDE A WHOLE HOST OF BENEFITS
THE SORT OF ECOSYSTEM SERVICES
TO HUMANS THEY. PROVIDE.
HOW IMPORTANT HABITAT FOR
COMMERCIAL AND RECREATIONAL
FISHERIES? THEY CAN HELP ACCRETE
SEDIMENT AND REDUCE WAVE ENERGY
TO PROTECT OUR SHORELINES REDUCE
EROSION BY THE SYSTEMS CAN
SEQUESTER CARBON. AND AS YOU'LL
HEAR LATER THEY THEY CAN HELP
BUFFER FROM OCEAN ACIDIFICATION.
AND LET'S HARD TO READ BUT AND.
AS I SAID THE SYSTEMS DO
SEQUESTER CARBON AND.
THE CAUSE OF CONSERVANCY WORKED
WITH THE DELTA CONSERVANCY NDW
ARE.
ENDS WHEN ROCK AMERICAN CARBON
REGISTRY TO DEVELOP A PROTOCOL
FOR CARBON SEQUESTRATION OF
COASTAL AND FRESHWATER WETLANDS
IN CALIFORNIA. THAT'S IN THE
VOLUNTARY CARBON.
.
SYSTEM AND THE RATES ARE REALLY
REALLY HIGH. UP FOR EELGRASS AND
SEAGRASSES WE KNOW GLOBALLY THAT
THOSE SYSTEMS ARE VERY IMPORTANT
IN THEIR CONTRIBUTION TO CARBON
SEQUESTRATION. BUT WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE ENOUGH DATA IN
CALIFORNIA TO ASSESS HOW OUR
SPECIES PERFORM YOU GUYS CAN
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG BUT I
THINK THIS IS TRUE THAT WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW IT UP. AND ONE OF
THE BIG GAPS AS WE ACTUALLY
DON'T HAVE GREAT MAPPING
STATEWIDE OF EELGRASS ANNUAL
GRASS POTENTIAL.
AND SO THAT'S A THAT'S A DATA
NEED.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT A COUPLE OF THE
PILOT PROJECTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN YEAH. AND THIS IS A
PICTURE OF SOME HELP RESTORATION
THAT HAS BEEN DONE IN SANTA
MONICA BAY THE BAY FOUNDATION
BEGAN. HELP RESTORATION TWENTY
YEARS AGO THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY PROVIDED FUNDING IN
THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS.
AND REALLY WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS
GOING INTO.
URCHIN BARONS AND REDUCING THE
DENSITY OF THE URCHINS. I'M
WHERE THEY HAD WHERE THEY BECOME
REALLY REALLY DANCE THAT HELP IT
IT DECIMATES THE KELP FOREST AND
THEY FIND THAT IF THEY REDUCE
THE DENSITY IS. THAT THE KELP
ACTUALLY COMES BACK UP AND SOME
OF THE SITES HAVE PERSISTED FOR
A LONG TIME.
WE HAVE A CURRENT GRANT WITH THE
BAY FOUNDATION TO STUDY THAT.
A FACT OF THE KELP ON WAVE
ATTENUATION AND TO THIS MEASURE
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S ANY
PHYSICAL BENEFIT TO THE
SHORELINE.
THAT DATA COLLECTION IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW SO WE ARE
HOPING TO HAVE A REPORT OUT.
TOWARDS THE END OF THE YEAR.
IN YEAH SAN FRANCISCO BAY WE'VE
IN THE. BEEN INVOLVED IN A
NUMBER OF SUBTITLE HABITAT
PROJECTS.
I WAS SUPPORT FROM THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL THE
CONSERVANCY HELPED DEVELOP THE
SAN FRANCISCO SUBTITLE HABITAT
GOALS REPORT. WHICH IS REALLY A
LONG TERM FIFTY YEAR PLAN FOR
SUBTITLE HABITAT RESTORATION IN
SAN FRANCISCO BAY IT WAS REALLY
THE FIRST TIME. LOOK AT THE
SUBTITLE OPPORTUNITIES AND WE
APPRECIATE A PC SUPPORT OF THAT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IT
RECOMMENDED WAS THAT WE START TO
DO PILOT RESTORATIONPROJECTS
WITH A REAL EXPERIMENTAL DESIGN.
AND SO WE HAVE BEEN DOING PATS
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH SEVEN
CISCO STATE AND KATHY PLAYERS
LACK OF BEEN LEADING THAT
SCIENCE.
DOING PILOT RESTORATION PROJECTS
WHERE WE PLANT YOUR GRASS WE
INSTALL THEM.
OYSTER SUBSTRATE AND NOW AND SEE
IF THE OYSTERS WILL COME BACK.
I AND NUMBER MONITORING BOTH THE
BIOLOGICAL RESPONSE AND THE
PHYSICAL BENEFITS OF THOSE
PROJECTS CAN THEY ACTUALLY
REDUCE WAVE ENERGY AT THE SHORE.
DO WE SEE SETTLEMENT ACCRETION.
DEAN OF THE NEXT SLIDE.
AND.
.
THEY'RE INCREDIBLY PRODUCTIVE.
AMAZING RESPONSE FROM THE
SYSTEMS WE HAD TWO MILLION
OYSTERS WHAT IT WITH AN ESTIMATE
BUT. THAT'S THE WAY THAT I IN
THE FIRST YEAR AND WE'RE SEEING
REALLY DRAMATIC.
SURVIVAL OF THE L. GRASS.
AND SOME.
SOME ENERGY DISSIPATION AND
PRETTY AYE EXCITING LEVELS OF
SEDIMENTATION SO WE THINK IT CAN
BE PART OF AN INTEGRATED
STRATEGY. FOR HELPING AND.
ADOPTED CLIMATE CHANGE AND
HELPING TO BRING BACK THE
SYSTEMS.
I'M HERE TO THE NEXT SLIDE I
WANNA PUT A LITTLE BIT OF A WORD
OF CAUTION IT'S HARD TO EVEN
REMEMBER. THE LAST WINTER WAS
VERY DIFFERENT FROM THE SWEATER.
AND SAN FRANSISCO BAY THAT BIG
CHART SHOWS THE SALINITY IN SAN
FRANCISCO BAY WHICH ACTUALLY
TURNED INTO A FRESH WATER SYSTEM
FOR. A PRETTY PROLONGED PERIOD
OF TIME THAT THERE WAS SO MUCH
FRESH WATER COMING OUT.
AND THAT PRETTY MUCH DECIMATED
OUR YELL GRASS AND OUR OYSTERS.
NOT ENTIRELY UNEXPECTED WE KNOW
THE SYSTEMS FLUCTUATE WE KNOW
THE BAY FLUCTUATES. BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT AS WE THINK ABOUT
HOW TO USE. THE SYSTEMS TO HELP.
.
PROVIDE ECOSYSTEM SERVICES AND
ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE TO REALIZE THAT THEY'RE
ALSO GOING TO BE AT THE FRONT
LINES OF TAKING THE HITS.
OF CRIME VARIABILITY AND KIND
IMPACTS.
AND IT REALLY IS IMPORTANT TO
HAVE THE PARTNERSHIP THAT WE DID
WAS TERENCE'S CHO STATE WHERE
THEY WERE MONITORING IN REAL
TIME.
THE SYSTEM SO WE KNEW THAT WE
HAD THE BOSS OF THE OYSTERS AND
YELL GRASS.
AND NOW WE'RE MONITORING THE
RECOVERY OF THE SYSTEMS
I'M AND I SHOULD SAY IT WASN'T
JUST A RESTORED SITES BUT ILL
GRASS AND MANY PARTS OF THE BAY
THAT HAD BEEN THERE FOR DECADES.
WAS ALSO IMPACTED BY THIS EVENT.
AND AND WE'RE WORKING WITH SANTA
TO ALSO FIGURE OUT WHERE WE'RE
GONNA GO BACK CAN BE PLANT SO.
THAT'S MY OTHER POINT IS THAT I
THINK.
SO I THINK THE PARTNERSHIPS ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT BUT ALSO THAT
THIS ISN'T RESTORATION
NECESSARILY LIKE YOU BUILD AT
ONCE AND.
AND YOU'RE GOOD TO GO.
BUT WE MAY NEED TO ACTUALLY
COME BACK AND REPLANT SOME OF
THE SITES WE MAY NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE BALANCE.
AND.
THAT WE HELP PRESERVE THE
BALANCE AND AND PRESERVE THESE
ECOSYSTEM FUNCTIONS. INTO THE
NOT SLIDE THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
EXAMPLE WHICH YOU VERY WELL MAY
HAVE HEARD ABOUT BUT. IN THE
NORTH COAST AND THAT ABOVE HOT
WATER BLOB IN THE OCEAN THE SEAS
ARE WASTING DISEASE HAS LED TO.
I'M CREATION OF VIRGIN BARREN
SPENT A REALLY DRAMATIC LOSS OF
THE CAL.
AND AGAIN.
THAT'S SORT OF THE IMPACTS OF
THESE CLIMATIC VARIABILITY
PLAYING OUT ON THE SYSTEMS.
BY I THINK THE HOPEFUL PART OF
THAT YOU CAN GET THE LAST SLIDE.
IS THAT WE'RE SEEING THESE
PARTNERSHIPS OF
STATE AGENCIES RESEARCHERS
FISHERMEN.
HAPPY HAPPY RESEARCHERS. PLAYING
IN THE MUD AND BY COMING
TOGETHER AND AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW HOW WE CAN HELP
RESTORE THE SYSTEMS AND. AND
MOVE FORWARD.
RIGHT NOW I'M SORRY AS MOST
INTRODUCED.
BE THAT. AS I WOULDN'T IT OVER
THE GREEN AND YELLOW. THANK YOU.
MY NAME AND FOR CONTEXT TO THIS
IS BAD SORT OF TOP DOWN IF YOU
WILL.
THAT'S RESOURCES AGENCY OSHA
PROTECTION COUNCIL BECAUSE
CONSERVANCY AND NOW AND KARINA.
SUBMERGED AQUATIC VEGETATION
OCEANS EDUCATION WORKING GROUP
OF THE SCIENCE ADVISORY. TEAM
FOR THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL
KIND OF WORKING ON THIS QUESTION
SORE STARTING NARROW GETTING
MORE SPECIFIC AND INTO A LITTLE
BIT MORE THE SCIENTIFIC DETAILS.
FOR A MOVE ON THE NEXT PANEL SO
WHEN I FINISH THIS PANEL THEN
WILL TAKE QUESTIONS FROM.
FROM THE DIET SO CLEAN AND GREEN
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE. ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
BIKING VERITY INTRODUCE ME SO I
WON'T SAY MY NAME AGAIN.
BUT WE ARE HERE AS CO CHAIRS OF
THIS.
WORKING GROUP ON SUBMERGED
AQUATICVEGETATION.
WHICH PARTICULAR FOCUS ON SEA
GRASS OR ILL GRASSES AND CAL.
AND HOW IT MAY BE USEFUL AS AN
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION MANAGEMENT
TOOL IN CALIFORNIA MORE
SPECIFICALLY.
AS. YOU UNDOUBTEDLY KNOW ANNA'S
EMERGED FROM.
NUMEROUS STUDIES INCLUDING OUR
OWN.
WEST COAST.
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION HYPOXIA
PANEL THE US WEST COAST IS
EXPOSED TO SOME OF THE LOWEST
AND MOST VARIABLE P. H. WATERS
RECORDED ON A FOR THE SURFACE
OCEAN.
HUMAN CAUSED OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION ARE AWAY IS
INCREASING THE ACIDITY OF THESE
WATERS AND THE US WEST COAST IS
ONE OF THE FIRST PLACES WHERE WE
EXPECT TO SEE. BIOLOGICAL
IMPACTS OF OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
SO.
ECHOING THE REMARK THAT WE ARE
ON THE FRONT LINES HERE.
NICK SITE PLEASE.
OUR GROUP WAS CHARGED WITH.
THINKING ABOUT HOW RESTORATION
PROTECTION AND CULTIVATION OF
COASTAL AN EXTREME SUBMERGED
AQUATIC VEGETATION YOU'LL SEE
IT.
SOMETIMES IN THE PRESENTATION
ABBREVIATED AS SAB AT THAT
REFERS THAT HELP IN THE SEA
GRASSES ON HOW HOW THIS
VEGETATION UNDERWATER MAY
CONTRIBUTE. TO CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE CHANGE ADAPTATION AND
MITIGATION STRATEGIES.
THAT WAS OUR QUESTION.
OF COURSE I LIKE ALL PLANTS.
THE SUBMERGED AQUATIC
VEGETATION PHOTOSYNTHESIZE IS.
TAKES.
THE ENERGY FROM LIGHT TAKES
CARBON DIOXIDE THAT'S IN THE
WATER CONVERTS IT INTO PLANT BY
AMOUNTS IT RELEASES OXYGEN IN
THE PROCESS REQUIRES LIGHT. AND
AS YOU CAN SEE UNDER CERTAIN
SITUATIONS AND THOSE FRANZ RIGHT
THERE THOSE THOSE BLADES OF
GRASS THAT BUBBLES ON THEM FROM
THE PRODUCTION OF OXYGEN SYSTEM
YOU DON'T OFTEN GET TO SEE AN
AIR BUT IT'S. AN INTERESTING
PHENOMENON TO VISUALIZE THERE SO
THAT'S WHAT SUBMERGED AQUATIC
VEGETATION HOUSE TO DO WITH
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION IT'S THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN THEIR PROCESS
AND PHOTOSYNTHESIS ON THE WAY
THAT THEY REMOVE IT AND
TRANSFORM IT INTO BIOMASS.
SO THERE ARE TWO WAYS IN WHICH
SEAGRASS AND HELP MAY BE
BENEFICIAL TO CLIMATE CHINA
CHANGE ADAPTATION AND
MITIGATION.
THROUGH AMELIORATION AND THEIR
ABILITY TO INCREASE PH IN THE
WATER THROUGH THIS PROCESS OF
PHOTOSYNTHESIS.
ON AND THEIR POTENTIAL TO
SEQUESTER OR STORE CARTMAN SO
CALLED BLUE CARBON.
THROUGH A VARIETY OF WAYS NEXT
SLIDE.
THE AMELIORATION PIECE
IS THE PART THAT YOU WILL
PROBABLY HEAR MOST ABOUT TODAY.
AND THAT IS THE WAYS IN WHICH
ACTIVE PHOTOSYNTHESIS CAN
ACTUALLY INCREASE THE PH A
REDUCE THE EXPOSURE ARE TOO
ACIDIC WATERS BY ORGANISMS ARE
BETTER LIVING WITHIN THE
SEAGRASS BETTER THE KELP FORESTS
DEPENDING ON WHICH SYSTEM WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
AND POTENTIAL.
FOR.
ORGANISMS NEARBY POTENTIALLY TO
BENEFIT AS WELL.
SO I.
THE SEQUESTRATION PIECE REFERS
TO.
LONGER TERM PROCESS SEES WHERE
AND.
THE C. GROUSE AND THE KELP MAY
SERVE AS A NATURAL CARBON SINK
STORING CARBON POTENTIALLY FOR
DECADES TO MILLENNIA AND THESE
ARE THROUGH PROPHECIES OF BURIAL
AND TRANSPORT. WITHIN THE KELP
FOREST.
THE MAIN MECHANISM BY WHICH
THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE
TO SEQUESTRATION IS BY TRANSPORT
OF THE CALPERS ACTUALLY INTO
VERY DEEP SEA HABITATS AND GETS
SORT OF STUCK THERE ARE FEW
WELL.
FOR LONG TERM.
FOR THE.
SEAGRASS BEDS THERE ARE COUPLE
OF MECHANISMS BUT PRIMARILY IT'S
BURIAL OF BIOMASS FROM THE SEA
GRASS THEMSELVES POSSIBLY FROM
PARTICULATE MATTER THE WAY THAT
IT FILTERS DOWN INTO THE BEDS
AND BURIAL IN THE SETTLEMENTS
UNDERNEATH THE ROOTS AND AND
THEIR.
THE SUBSTRATE BY THE SEA GRASS
ITSELF
NEXT.
SO THE KEY STATES US ARE THE KEY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE STATE IS
WORKING TO ADDRESS.
ARE ARE THESE DO USE THE
SUBMERGED AQUATIC VEGETATION
HABITATS.
MEASURABLY LESSEN THE SEVERITY
OF OCEAN ACIDIFICATION EXPOSURE.
AND IF THEY DO WHEN AND WHERE
AND UNDER WHAT CONDITIONS
I DID THESE HABITATS BEST
PERFORM THIS FUNCTION OF
AMELIORATING.
THE ACIDITY OF THE WATER.
AND CAN THE SUBMERGED AQUATIC
VEGETATION HABITATS BE MANAGED
IN A WAY THAT ACTUALLY REDUCES
THE ENVIRONMENTAL STRAUSS OF
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION ON THE
SPECIES THAT WE HAVE ALONG THE
WEST COAST.
TOWARD THAT END THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL SCIENCE
ADVISORY TEAM CONVENED A WORKING
GROUP.
AND WORKING WITH OCEAN SIGNED
TRUST ON BEHALF OF A PC AND
CALIFORNIA MANAGERS.
WE WERE CHARGED WITH
COMMUNICATING.
THE EMERGING SCIENTIFIC
UNDERSTANDING SUMMARIZING
KNOWLEDGE GAPS AND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR FILLING THEM THROUGH
RESEARCH AND MONITORING AND TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE ON NEXT STEPS
SO OF THIS WAS THAT WORKING
GROUP THAT GOT CONVENIENT.
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF
THE DIVERSITY OF EXPERTISE THAT
WAS BROUGHT TO BEAR ON IT.
THERE WERE TEN RESEARCH
SCIENTISTS THREE OF THEM ARE
MEMBERS OF THE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL SCIENCE ADVISORY TEAM
THEMSELVES THERE WERE SEVEN
UNIVERSITIES. ARE REPRESENTED
INCLUDING SEVEN FOLKS FROM
UNIVERSITIES EXCUSE ME FROM THE
CSU THE UC SYSTEM IN OREGON
STATE UNIVERSITY ONE OF THE
SCIENTISTS WAS FROM A RESEARCH
INSTITUTE THE. MONTEREY BAY
AQUARIUM RESEARCH INSTITUTE ONE
WAS A CALIFORNIA SEA GRANT
EXTENSIONS SPELL SPECIALIST.
THEY WERE SUPPORTED BY THREE
SCIENTIFIC STOP FROM THE OCEAN
SCIENCE TRUST
AND WE CAN BE IN A WORKSHOP.
WHICH INCLUDED ADDITIONAL.
OF FOLKS TO MAKE THE SCIENCE
REAL A FEW WELL CONNECTED TO FOR
POLICYMAKERS MANAGERS FROM
CALIFORNIA AND AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
OPC STAFF OF IS TO STAFF BUT TO
FOLKS FROM NGOS AM I WON
ADDITIONAL SCIENTIFIC EXPERT WHO
WAS NOT A MEMBER OF THE WORKING
GROUP.
THE FINDINGS ARE NOW AVAILABLE
THAT CAME OUT THEY WERE RELEASED
JANUARY THIRTIETH SO YOU CAN.
BEGIN TO THE DETAILS THERE.
NICE.
BOOKLET AND.
WITHOUT I'M GOING TO.
I THINK THE NEXT SLIDE IS YOU
I'M GONNA PASS ON TO MY
COLLEAGUE AND CO CHAIR OF THAT
WORKING GROUP.
J. STOCKTWITS FROM UC DAVIS.
GREAT THANK YOU KARINA AND
THANKS CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
I THINK WHAT I'D LIKE TO START
WITH IS JUST HERE ARE SOME OF
THE.
ORGANISMS THAT YOU'VE BEEN
HEARING ABOUT HERE THE PLANTS
THAT ARE DOING THE WORK.
MOSTLY WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
YOUR GRASS WERE TALKING ABOUT
ZOSTER MARINA AT STATEWIDE
OCCURS FROM FROM BORDER TO
BORDER. THERE'S ALSO ANOTHER
SPECIES CALLED ZOSTER PACIFICA
WHICH LOOKS VERY SIMILAR AND
IT'S A BIT BIGGER BUT YOU'LL
FIND IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT HELP THERE'S
MOSTLY TWO SPECIES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE GIANT KELP.
WHICH IS PUBLIC THE ONE
EVERYBODY'S MOST FAMILIAR WITH
THAT'S MOSTLY IN THEIR CENTRAL
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THEN
THE BULL KELP.
WHICH IS MOSTLY CENTRAL TO
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SO THOSE ARE
MOST OR TALK ONLY SAKE HELP.
THAT'S A PICTURE OF WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT YOUR GRASS ITS BIT USUALLY
ZOSTER MARINA BUT IT MAY BE
EITHER OF THOSE.
OKAY SO HERE'S WHAT WE'RE SORT
OF HERE FOR RIGHT.
THERE ARE THESE AT THE KEY
FINDINGS
SO THE FIRST ONE IS A YES OKAY
WE CAN SAY THAT YES.
SERVERS AQUATIC VEGETATION CAN
LOCALLY INCREASE THE WATER PH BY
THE MECHANISMS THAT KARINA WAS
ALLUDING TO.
THEY TAKE UP CARBON DIOXIDE AND
REDUCE THE P. H. AS A RESULT OF
THAT.
COURSE THE BIG QUESTIONS IS
WHERE HOW MUCH AND AND AND AND
WHAT IS IT YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE
ULTIMATE EFFECT OF THAT WE KNOW
THINGS LIKE THE LONGER THE WATER
STAYS IN THAT. SEAGRASS BETTER
KELP FOREST THE GREATER THE
EFFECT.
WE KNOW THAT THE GREATER THE
PHOTO SYNTHETIC RATE THE GREATER
THE EFFECT.
BUT CUT PIECING ALL THOSE
TOGETHER INTO EXACTLY A PICTURE
OF WHERE AND WHEN THE AFFECTS
OUR GREATEST IS WHERE WERE
WORKING ON RIGHT NOW.
GOOD NEXT SIDE.
SO HOW BIG IS THAT AFFECT THAT'S
WHAT WE'D ALL LIKE TO KNOW. AND.
THE THE FIRST MESSAGE TO SORT
OF GET ACROSS FROM THIS IS THAT
OF COURSE YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD
ANY SCIENTIST TELLS YOU WELL IT
DEPENDS.
IT VARIES.
AND AND IT DOES BUT I'M GONNA
TRY TO TELL YOU LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT IT DEPENDS ON AND OF COURSE
IF YOU KNOW THAT. FROM WHAT
KARINA TOLD YOU THAT FOR THE
SYNTHESIS DEPENDS ON LIKE YOU
KNOW IT'S GONNA VERY TO THE
COURSE OF THE DAY RIGHT DURING
THE DAY WHEN THE PLANTS ARE
ACTIVELY GROWING IN TAKING UP
CARBON DIOXIDE. THE P. H. WILL
GO UP AS THE CO TWO IS USED AT
NIGHT WHEN THE PLANT STOP VOTER
SYNTHESIZING AND THEY'RE
ACTUALLY RESPIRE IN MORE POOR OR
PUTTING OUT CARBON DIOXIDE THE
P. H. MAY GO DOWN SO YOU CAN SEE
THERE. ON THIS.
ON ON THIS GRAPH I HOPE THIS
WILL REACH APPEAR NOT BUT YOU
CAN SEE THAT THE.
THE THE VARIATION INSIDE A
SEAGRASS BED MIGHT BE PART
EXPECTED TO BE LARGER THEN THE
VARIATION OUTSIDE SEACREST BUT
NO THE WORDS. THE HIGHS ARE
HIGHER IN THE LOW'S ARE LOWER
INSIDE THAT INSIDE THAT
SUBMERGED AQUATIC VEGETATION
THAT GOT.
RIGHT SO THAT'S THOSE ARE
BASICALLY THAT YOU KNOW SHOWING
THAT GAP. AND.
DOCTORS HILL AND.
NICHOLS WILL BE TELLING YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME OF THIS
VARIATION LATER ON WHEN THEY
PRESENT THE RESULTS OF SOME OF
THEIR OPC FUNDED FUNDED WORK.
NEXT THING THAT WE ARE OF COURSE
NEED TO KNOW ABOUT AS WE DON'T
JUST WANT TO KNOW ABOUT. P. H.
FOR PIZZA SAKE BUT WHAT AFFECT
DOES IT ACTUALLY HAVE ON THE
PLANTS AND ANIMALS THAT ARE
LIVING IN SEAGRASSES WHAT'S THE
REAL BY OFFERING AFFECT NOT FROM
A CHEMICAL PERSPECTIVE FROM A
BIOLOGICAL PERSPECTIVE.
SO FOR EXAMPLE MOST OF WHAT WE
KNOW.
IS.
HOW DOES SOMETHING LIKE AN
OYSTER GROW MORE OR LESS WHEN WE
CHANGE THE AVERAGE P. H.?
RIGHT SO YOU CAN SEE THE AVERAGE
INSIDE THE BAD IS A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER THAN THE AVERAGE OUTSIDE
THE BED. SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
OKAY WE CAN TEST THAT'S MOSTLY
WHAT WE'VE DONE SO FAR.
BUT WHAT IF WHAT REALLY MATTERS
IS THE HIGHS
GO AHEAD.
RIGHT WHAT IF THAT GOT MORE MORE
SO WHAT IF THE MAXIMUM IS WHAT
MATTERS RIGHT OR WHAT IF THE
MINIMUM IS WHAT REALLY MATTERS.
AND YOU CAN THINK ABOUT THIS A
FEW YOU KNOW HAD ANY SORT OF
INCLINATION TO GROW PLANTS OR A
GARDEN WHAT USUALLY LIMITS
PLANTS GROWING PLANTS HERE
LOCALLY IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
IS OFTEN LOW TEMPERATURES IN THE
WINTER RIGHT WE CAN'T GROW A LOT
OF TROPICAL THINGS HERE BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T WITHSTAND FREEZING.
AND YOU MIGHT THINK THAT'S SORT
OF THE ANALOGOUS THING MIGHT GO
ON IN OUR AND OUR GRASS BEDS IN
OTHER WORDS IT MIGHT NOT BE THE
AVERAGE CONDITION THAT MATTER SO
MUCH. BUT IT MIGHT BE DOES IT
REALLY YOU KNOW IF THESE OYSTERS
ARE ARE ARE LAYING DOWN SHALL
DURING THE DAY THAN THAT HUGE
BENEFIT DURING THE DAY MIGHT BE
A REALLY BIG DEAL.
RIGHT SO SO WE TO THINK NOT JUST
ABOUT BUTTON THE MEAN CHANGES.
BUT THE AVERAGE CHANGE.
AND WHAT THOSE DO BIOLOGICALLY.
BUT NEXT LIKE.
SO I'M I KNOW ONE ECHO SOMETHING
THAT THAT MARY SAID EARLIER AND
THAT IS THAT. THE THE GOOD NEWS
HERE IS THAT WE ALREADY NOW
THAT SEAGRASSES IN CULTS DO A
LOT OF GOOD THINGS FOR
ECOSYSTEMS AND AND FOR HUMANS
WHETHER IT'S PROVIDING HABITAT.
FISHES FOR CRABS FOR LOBSTERS
BOTH COMMERCIALLY AND
RECREATIONAL IMPORTANT FISHERIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA OR WHETHER
IT'S TRACKING DOWN THE SORT OF
COASTAL EROSION PROTECTION
THINGS THAT MARY TOLD THE SIR.
ARE GOING ON IT WE ALREADY KNOW
HAPPENING IN SOME SEA GRASS BEDS
WE KNOW THERE ARE A BUNCH OF
THINGS THAT THE SEA GRASSES AND
CELTS ALREADY DO. AND SO THEN
THE QUESTION IS WHAT ELSE DID
THEY DO WHAT ADDITIONAL BENEFIT
CAN WE GET IN TERMS OF AWAY
WHILE DOING ALL THESE THINGS
THAT WE ALREADY KNOW OUR BIG
POSITIVE I'M FROM THE SWORDS
AQUATIC VEGETATION.
SO LET ME.
TAKE A SECOND TO JUST INTRODUCE
OUR OUR NEXT GROUP JUST SO YOU
KNOW HOW THEY'RE GONNA FIT INTO
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TESSA
HILL. ABDUCTOR TESSA HILL GONNA
LEAD US OFF. AND AND SHE HAS
BEEN DOING WORK.
ASSOCIATE WITH THE O. P. C..
THAT ASKS THE QUESTIONS ABOUT
WELL WHAT LOCATIONS FOR EELGRASS
SHOWED THE MOST PROMISE.
ARE THERE SOME PLACES WHERE THE
EFFECTS ARE GREATER OR LOWER.
YOU KNOW WHAT CAN WE WHAT WHAT
DO WE KNOW ABOUT THAT SO FAR.
AND THEN SHE'LL BE FOLLOWED BY
SIR NEWKIRK FROM THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WHO WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WE OFTEN THINK ABOUT
HOW SEAGRASS MIGHT COMPETE WITH
OTHER SORTS OF USES IN IN
COASTAL SYSTEMS. LIKE
AQUACULTURE BUT IF SEAGRASSES
INCREASE.
PH THERE MIGHT ALSO BE BENEFITS
TO AQUACULTURE OTHER SORTS OF
OPERATIONS AND SHE'S GONNA TALK
ABOUT BALANCING THOSE THOSE
NEEDS.
AND AND OUR OUR LAST SPEAKER
WILL BE CARRY NICHOLS DOCTOR
CHEMICALS AND CAL STATE
NORTHRIDGE WHO WILL BE FOR
SHIFTING THE FOCUS FROM EELGRASS
TO THINKING ABOUT HELPS.
AND WE KNOW FROM FOR EXAMPLE
WHAT MARY SHOWED US THAT HELPS
ARE DECLINING THROUGHOUT. A
LARGE PART OF CALIFORNIA AND
CARRIES WORK ON THE EFFECTS OF
KELP ON.
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION AND AND P.
H. WILL TELL US SOMETHING ABOUT
WHAT THE IMPACTS OF THAT MIGHT
BE IN TERMS OF OF AFTER SHELF
FORMING ORGANISMS.
SO THAT'S WHAT YOU'LL BE SEEING
IN THE SECOND PANEL AND I THINK
AT THAT POINT THAT'S THAT'S IT
FROM OUR PANEL AND. WOULD BE
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE IF THERE ARE ANY
OKAY GOOD THANK YOU YEAH I DO
HAVE SOME AND I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT. OTHER MEMBERS HERE.
ARE ALSO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TO ASK AND I'M GLAD MAYOR WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THE INTERTIDAL
AND THE. THE TITLE AREAS ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE IN OUR
PLANNING HOW WE DEAL WITH THINGS
IS WE TEND TO DO. LAND BASED
PLANNING OCEAN PLANNING
COMPLETELY SEPARATE FROM EACH
OTHER AND FROM THIS.
SO FAR EVEN IN THIS DISCUSSION
IS VERY VERY CLEAR THAT WE HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT WE HAVE TO BE A
LITTLE BIT SMARTER ABOUT THOSE
THINGS. AND THE.
THE FRESHWATER CHALLENGES THAT
YOU BROUGHT UP WITH THE THE
FLUSH OF FRESH WATER GOING INTO
THE SAME CISCO BANG. THOSE AS TO
OUR SYSTEMS ARE OUR NATURAL
BUFFERS
AND WE HAVE TAKEN AWAY OVER
TIME.
THE ABILITY FOR THOSE BUFFERS TO
REACT AND DO WHAT THEY NEED TO
DO THERE'D BEEN TIMES IN THE
PAST WHERE THERE PROBABLY WAS.
PLENTY VIA GRASSES AND CISCO BAY
CLEARED OUT BECAUSE OF.
LOTS OF RAIN EVENT IN THE
WINTERTIME BUT THEN IT WAS ABLE
TO RECOVER.
SO FOR US THIS WHEN THE
CHALLENGES RE ESTABLISHING SOME
OF THOSE NATURAL SYSTEMS
TO THE BEST WAY. THAT WE.
THAT WE POSSIBLY CAN BUT MS HUBS
I TUCKED BUT YOU MENTIONED AND
SECTARIAN BLARED MENTION SO
BRIEFLY THIS INTERNATIONAL
WORKING GROUP GROUP.
WHICH
HAS.
QUITE AN INTERESTING GROUP OF
COUNTRIES WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
IN ANY AND I JUST HAVE TO POINT
OUT OF COURSE CALIFORNIA. IS
REPRESENTING. THAT THE UNITED
STATES SEEMS TO BE REPRESENTING
BUT CALIFORNIA IS WE'RE STEPPING
IN FOR THAT NATIONAL EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE SUB NATIONAL JURISDICTION.
WHAT'S WHAT EXPECTATIONS WHAT'S
THE PLAN WITH A PROCESS FOR THAT
INTERNATIONAL WORKING GROUP CEO
AND THE INTERNATIONAL WORKING
GROUP IS EN A COLLABORATION OF
SUBNATIONAL GROUPS ACADEMIC
GROUPS NGOS. AND TRIBES.
PRETTY MUCH AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO RAISE AWARENESS OF THE
ISSUE OF OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
INTERNATIONALLY. AND THEN TAKE
CONCRETE STEPS TO ADDRESS
A PROBLEM SO EACH JURISDICTION
THAT JOINS THE ALLIANCE IS
SUPPOSED TO DEVELOP AN ACTION
PLAN THAT LAYS OUT WHAT STEPS
THEY'RE GONNA TAKE. AT THEIR
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL DID TO DEAL
WITH THE PROBLEMS OF CALIFORNIA
AND IS IN THE PROCESS NOW OF
DEVELOPING OUR ACTION PLAN WE
JUST LAST WEEK FUNDED.
O. S. T. TO HELP US DEVELOP THE
COMMUNICATION AND MATERIALS AND
OUTREACH AND DEVELOP KIND OF THE
PLAN THAT WE'RE GONNA BE MAKING
WERE WORKING WITH A GROUP OF
SCIENTISTS. AND SOME OF THE SAME
SCIENTISTS WHO HELPED DEVELOP
THE AS.
THE SCIENCE PANEL AND THEN A
COUPLE OF ADDITIONAL SCIENTISTS
WHO WERE ON BOARD TO HELP
ANSWER.
WHATEVER SCIENTIFIC QUESTIONS
AND WE NEED WHATEVER KIND OF.
APPROACH WE NEED TO DEVELOP IT
TO HELP CALIFORNIA MOVE FORWARD
IN ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM. AND.
JEFF THANK YOU DAY AND AND THANK
FOR THAT THAT THAT WAS.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE WAS
EXPLAINED BECAUSE NOT ONLY. ARE
WE DOING THIS BECAUSE OF. SOME
OF THE LEGISLATION AND INTEREST
IN THE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS IN ADDRESSING THIS BUT ALSO
THE CONTEXT OF. THESE
INTERNATIONAL. AGREEMENTS
INTERNATIONAL.
COORDINATION THAT'S GOING ON SO
WE'RE DOING AN ACTION PLAN OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE DOING ACTION
PLANS.
AND.
THIS IS NOT AN ISSUE WE'RE GONNA
OF ASSAULT BY OURSELVES NOBODY'S
GONNA HAFTA LOOK AT THAT. GLOBAL
IMPACT AND I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE BENEFITS OF THE WEST COAST
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION PANEL IS
THAT IT WAS THAT A COLLABORATION
AMONG CALIFORNIA WASHINGTON
OREGON AND BRITISH COLUMBIA. AND
THERE'S REAL STRENGTH THERE AND
SHOWING AND THE IMPACTS TO THE
ENTIRE WEST COAST AND THAT WHEN
NONE OF US ARE NOT ALLOWED WE'RE
ALL GONNA NEED TO WORK TOGETHER
WE HAVE ON OUR SCIENCE PANEL. A
SCIENTIST FROM OREGON STATE
UNIVERSITY SO WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO YOU ACKNOWLEDGE THE.
THE BRASS OF THE PROBLEM IN THE
SCALE OF THE PROBLEM BUT AT THE
SAME TIME LOCALIZE OUR ACTIONS
TO MAKE A MEANINGFUL.
OKAY AND AND ONE ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES OF BRINGING SCIENCE
INTO THE LEGISLATURE IS OF
COURSE OUR DESIROUS TO OKAY
WOULD WE DID WHAT WE HAD WAS ON
PACIFIC LET'S GO. AND GET THE
SCIENCE IS DEVELOPING WHICH I
THINK IT'S PRETTY CLEAR FROM
HERE AND I DON'T.
I HOPE YOU'RE THEIR APPROPRIATE
FOLKS ASK OR THAT NECESSARILY
THE NEXT PANEL BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE LEARNED ALONG
THE WAY.
ABOUT THAT'S BEEN DEVELOPING AN
UNDERSTANDING THE ELKHORN SLOUGH
ABOUT SOME OF THE RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN SEA OTTERS.
EEL GRASS AND HOW NECESSARY THEY
THEY ARE FOR EACH OTHER.
LEADS US TO.
START TO LOOK AT BETTER THE
SYSTEMS
AND ASSUMING THIS IS ALL A PART
OF IT I THINK THERE WAS A BRIEF
MENTION IN THERE ABOUT SOME OF
THE SPECIES AND. AND OTHER.
IMPACTS AND IN INFLUENCES ON
THIS BECAUSE IF WE ARE GOING TO
PLAY REPLANT EELGRASS.
IF WE DO THAT WITHOUT AN
UNDERSTANDING OF ECOSYSTEMS IN
THE DANCE IS EXCESSIVE INCLUDING
OTHER SPECIES. THAT WE'RE JUST
PLAN SAYING HAVE IT REMOVED
PLANS A HAVING REMOVED OR NOT
GETTING ANYWHERE. ALIKE DUMPING
SAND ON BEACHES.
BUT THAT'S A DIFFERENT ISSUE.
AND AND SO THAT THAT I'M
ASSUMING IS A CONTEXT FOR ALL OF
HIS HOUSE HOW. ARE ALL OF THOSE
STUDIES GOING INTERLACE IN ORDER
FOR US TO UNDERSTAND. POLICIES
THAT WE COULD BE WORKING ON
HELPING TO PROVIDE AS WELL AS OF
COURSE FUNDING I DID NOTE THAT
THAT WAS DEFINITELY A BUDGET IN
THERE AND. THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'LL HAVE TO WORK OUT BETWEEN
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION MAKE SURE THAT WE
TAKE ALL THIS SERIOUSLY AND
FUNDING AT AND SECRETARY LEAD
WAS CORRECT.
THAT.
THE.
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS
HAD BEEN VERY VERY NARROWLY
CONSTRUED NOW I THINK WE CAN
START TO SEE HOW THEY CAN
BENEFIT THE ADAPTATION
CONVERSATION. THESE KINDS OF
PROJECTS AS OPPOSED JUST PURELY
MITIGATION ALTHOUGH WHAT WE TALK
ABOUT REALLY ENCOMPASSES.
BOTH SO THAT THAT BROADER
CONTEXT SPECIES EVERYTHING THAT
WE'RE LEARNING ABOUT HOW THESE
SYSTEMS INTERACT YEAH BUT IT.
I BE HAPPY TO SAY A FEW WORDS.
.
WE ARE OBVIOUSLY VERY COGNIZANT.
IN IN SOME WAYS WHEN WE PRESENT
THIS SNAPSHOT IF YOU WILL OF
WHAT WE'RE FINDING AND WE'VE
BEEN FOCUSING A BIT ON THE
PHYSICAL AND CHEMICAL ASPECTS OF
IT MORE THAN THE BIOLOGICAL. BUT
I WOULD SAY THAT IT'S
ALL OF US GOING TO SOME VERY
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT HOW WHERE
WHEN AND UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES IT'S ABOUT
EMBEDDING ALL OUR OTHER
KNOWLEDGE OF HOW THE SYSTEM
WORKS AND YOU'RE RIGHT SOMETIMES
A SPECIES THAT ARE IN THE
SYSTEM.
CAN IMPACT THE EFFICACY.
OF THESE RESPONSES
SO YES I THINK WHAT YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE GETTING IS THAT THE
SYNTHETIC.
SUMMARY CONCLUSIONS THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW BUT WE HAD ARE
VERY COGNIZANT OF ALL THOSE
OTHER PLAYERS.
IF THAT HELPS A LITTLE BIT AND
I AND I THINK WE'RE DOING
SOMETHING RIGHT IF YOU'RE ASKING
US THAT QUESTION.
WELL ANYTHING AND I KNOW IN
CONTEXT THAT THAT IS BEING
CONSIDERED BUT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT I THINK WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT. WE'RE REMINDING
OURSELVES OF THIS WOULD WHERE WE
ARE. IN THE INVESTIGATION.
HOW REALLY NICE AND A LOT OF
THIS IS IN IN OUR UNDERSTANDING
AND?
SO COMING UP WITH SOLUTIONS NEED
TO BE THOUGHTFUL AND WELL FRAME.
BASED ON THE SCIENCE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THEIR YOU KNOW
THERE ARE POTENTIAL TIPPING
POINTS THAT WE MAY BE COMING
CLOSER TO SO. THIS JUST THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS JUST PART OF
THE FRAMEWORK OF THINKING ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND HOW IT'S
IMPACTING ECOSYSTEMS.
WE UNDERSTAND A FAIR AMOUNT BUT
THEN THERE IS STILL THIS GREAT
UNCERTAINTY MAYBE JAY WITH I
HAVE LIKE MAYBE JUST JUST HAVE
TO TRY TO.
YOU KNOW GO BACK TO TEAR YOUR
QUESTION THEY'RE SORT OF LONG
THEN I THINK.
YOU KNOW IT WITHOUT A BORING YOU
WITH THE ARCANE NATURE OF IT TO
SORT OF GROUPS OF SCIENTISTS
INTERESTED IN YOUR GRASS.
THERE BEEN PLANT PEOPLE AND
THEY'RE BEEN ANIMAL PEOPLE
RIGHT SO. AND ALL PEOPLE DON'T
REALLY CARE ABOUT HOW THE PLANTS
WORK AS LONG AS THEY'RE THERE
AND PROVIDE PLACE FOR THE
ANIMALS TO LIVE.
AND.
THE YOU KNOW THE PLAN PEOPLE
DON'T REALLY CARE ABOUT THE
ANIMALS BECAUSE IT'S LIKE I JUST
LIKE PLANTS RIGHT. SO BUT NOW
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT AWAY IS
ACTUALLY DOING IS IT'S BRINGING
THOSE GROUPS TOGETHER.
BECAUSE
THERE THE CONNECTIONS ARE EVEN
MORE OBVIOUS NOW THAN THEY'VE
EVER BAD WHERE. NOT ONLY IS IT
JUST THE PHYSICAL STRUCTURE OF
THAT PLANT BUT IT'S HOW IT'S
CHANGING THE CHEMISTRY OF THE
WATER THAT AFFECTS THE ANIMALS
THEIR. ABILITY TO LAY DOWN
SHELVE THEIR BEHAVIOR AS.
YOU KNOW AS AS IN SELECTING
HABITATS IN THERE IT WHETHER
THEY EVEN COME THERE TO BEGIN
WITH.
AND AND SO I GUESS I'M I'M SORT
OF HOPEFUL THAT SOME OF THE
EFFORTS THAT BY THAT OP SEE IN
BOTH THE OTHER AWAY HYPOXIA
GROUP AND IN OUR ARE WORKING
GROUP IT'S ARE DONE. IS TO BRING
TOGETHER SOME SCIENTISTS WHO ARE
REALLY INTERESTED IN SORT OF
MESHING THOSE TWO PERSPECTIVES
TOGETHER. AND AND I GUESS WHAT
YOU KNOW.
MY PERSPECTIVE NOW IS THERE'S
PRETTY MUCH NO WAY TO THINK
ABOUT ONE WITHOUT THE OTHER IN
OTHER WORDS THERE'S JUST.
YOU KNOW THINKING ABOUT PLANT
PHYSIOLOGY OF SEA GRASS THAT'S
GREAT I MIGHT LOVE THAT BUT
THERE'S PRETTY MUCH NO WAY TO
THINK ABOUT THAT WITHOUT THE
ANIMALS FOR LOTS OF REASONS.
AND VICE VERSA SO SO I I REALLY
THINK THAT THAT EVEN THE SCIENCE
SIDE OF THINGS HAS THAT
SEPARATION THAT YOU'RE SORT OF
HINTING AT.
BUT IT'S IT'S COMING TOGETHER.
AS A RESULT OF THIS AND I THINK
THAT I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
YOU'LL SEE MORE OF THAT FROM.
FROM THE SCIENCE WERE GOING
FORWARD.
IT AND A GOOD POINT IF WE'RE
GONNA BE DOING POLICY WE WE'VE
GOT.
TO BRING A LOT OF THAT TOGETHER
JUST LOOKING AT YOUR GRAPHICS OF
THE KELP FOREST COVER.
MANY START.
AND IF WE'RE GOING TO BE RELYING
ON CAL EELGRASS IN ORDER TO HELP
AMELIORATE THE FACTS OF.
THAT THE PH CHANGES IN THE OCEAN
IF WE DON'T HAVE THOSE CUP
FOREST AGGRESSIVE BETS THAN.
THIS IS NICE BUT NOT GOING TO
REALLY GET AS.
ANYWHERE AND AS WE STAND IN
OTHER CONVERSATIONS AS WE TALK
ABOUT.
AQUACULTURE AND EVEN THEIR
NUMBER OF OPPORTUNITIES OVER THE
YEARS TO TO LOOK AT ALGAE'S
EDIBLE ALGAE'S IN THE OCEAN AS
PARTY AQUACULTURE. LET ALONE
SOME THE SHELLFISH WHICH ALSO
FILTER THE WATER AND HAVE AND
HAVE OTHER BENEFITS TO IT.
BUT A A COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY.
COULD FACILITATE AND.
ENTIRE ECONOMIC INDUSTRY AROUND
APPROPRIATELY DONE.
AQUACULTURE BUT ALSO RESTORING
THAT THE BULK OF THE NATURAL.
SYSTEMS THAT ARE OUT THERE THAT
HELP THE ILL GRASS SAID AND THE
WAY THAT THESE THESE ESTUARIES
WORK BECAUSE THEY YES WHERE YOU
ALSO ARE A PHYSICAL. BUFFER TO
THE CHANGES THE WATER FLOWS IN
SEES RISING IN SOME OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE THAT ARE OUT
THERE AND.
WE'VE TAKEN THOSE SYSTEMS
REGRET%
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME AND.
AS WE HEAR. THAT ONE THING I
JUST WANTED TO ADD TO THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE OPC ISRAELI
AN ECOSYSTEM BASED ORGANIZATION
WERE SUPPOSED TO BE THINKING
ABOUT. THE HEALTH OF THE ENTIRE
OCEAN ECOSYSTEM AND NOT JUST A
SPECIES BY SPECIES KIND OF
APPROACH AND. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT.
FOR SB WILLING TO EXPERIMENT AND
SEE BE BOLD AND TO THE
INNOVATIVE AND THAT MAY MEAN
THAT WE FUND SOME PROJECTS THAT
FAIL. AND AND THAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IN THE CONTEXT OF SEA
GRASS AND CAL BECAUSE WE JUST
DON'T KNOW. AND BUT.
IF WE WANT TO DO IT SECRETARY
LAIRD WAS SAYING AND MOVE THE
SCIENCE FOR IT BEFORE THE END OF
HIS NATURAL LIFE WE REMAIN NEEDS
YOU.
TO TAKE SOME THINGS ON FASTER
THAN WE WOULD OTHERWISE FEEL
COMFORTABLE DOING AND SO I THINK
THAT THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF. SOME OF
THE FUNDING REQUEST IS CAN WE DO
A PILOT PROJECT HERE CAN LEAD TO
A DEMONSTRATION PROJECT.
IN ORDER TO TEST
THESE THEORIES TO THEN BE ABLE
TO SCALE THEM UP.
AND I SAID THAT'S EXACTLY THE
POINT I WAS GOING TO MAKE AND I
THINK I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT.
WE BE MORE NIMBLE AND THAT WE
TAKE MORE RISKS.
AND STE YOU KNOW AS
JAY SAID WE WE KNOW THAT
RESTORATION OF THESE HABITATS IS
IT IS A NO REGRET STRATEGY. BUT
IF WE'RE ABLE TO DO IT IN A SORT
OF EXPERIMENTAL CONTEXT ARE ARE
PROJECTS IN SAN FRANCISCO BAY
BECAUSE SAN FRANCISCO'S STATE
IS.
REALLY AT.
MORE THAN PARTNER IN IT ANOTHER
CO DIRECTING THE SCIENCE PIECE
OF THAT WERE ABLE TO BE
COLLECTING A LOT OF INFORMATION
AND LEARNING AND I THINK YOU
KNOW THAT REYES RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA HOUSE TO.
BE WILLING TO FAIL BE WILLING TO
DO MORE EXPERIMENTAL KINDS OF
PROJECTS.
AND YOU KNOW.
RELATIVELY CONFIDENT THAT THAT
IF WE RESTORE THESE HABITATS
EVEN FOR A LITTLE WHILE THERE'S
SOME BENEFIT THERE. AND BUT IF
IT ALSO ADVANCES OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT'S THAT'S
WORTHWHILE TO AND AS. AS WE SEE
MORE CLIMATIC VARIABILITY WE
NEED TO BE MORE NIMBLE AND IN
HOW WE RESPOND.
IT AND I THINK THAT'S THAT'S A
VERY GOOD POINT OF COURSE WERE
THE LEGISLATURE AND NOTHING WE
DO HERE EVER VANNATTER WE'RE NOT
USED TO THAT. BUT.
THE IT IN AND.
THIS IS KIND OF WHY I THINK I'M
EXCITED BY THIS CONVERSATION AND
SOME OF. THE ABILITY TO TO LOOK
AHEAD BECAUSE IF THE SCIENCE IS
THERE AND THE SCIENCES SAW.
THEN
WHATEVER THE RESULT OF AN
INDIVIDUAL PROJECT.
AS LONG AS IT FITS INTO A A
LARGER.
PLAN AND PERSPECTIVE OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO THEN BY
DEFINITION IT'S REALLY NOT A
FAILURE. YET THE ALL THOSE
PAINTINGS HAVE SCHOOL BAY CASE
IN POINT YES THEY WERE PLANTING
YOU CAN SEE WHERE SOME OF THE U.
GRASS WAS WORKING.
THEN
A HUGE RAIN
VERY VERY WET WINTER COMES
CHANGES THE SALINITY OF THE BAY
CHANGES ALL OF THAT.
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED SOMETHING AND
ONE OF THINGS WILL BE
INTERESTING TO SEE HOW THOSE
SYSTEMS ARE COVER WHETHER THEY
NEED OUR ASSISTANCE OR WHETHER
WE CAN PUT ENOUGH IN PLACE?
BETTER WILL START TO WORK THE
WAY IT WOULD HAVE WORKED.
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
BEFORE WE HAD HARDENED THE BAY
AND REALLY CHANGE THOUGH SYSTEMS
IRREPARABLY.
AND THAT'S THAT'S THE VALUE
BECAUSE I WOULD HATE TO SEE US.
DO LIKE MY COMMENT THE WORKING
VERY WELL. MAY BE
THAT WAS A GOOD THING TO
UNDERSTAND BUT IF WE'RE RELYING
ON A PROJECT TO BE THE FINAL
SOLUTION FOR A MITIGATION.
THAT'S A LITTLE SCARY BUT IF WE
HAVE A BROADER PLAN. THAT IS
SCIENCE BASED ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE DOING THEN WE HAVE
SOME ABILITY FOR SOME SUCCESS IN
FOR SOME LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
AS. AS WE MOVE THROUGH AND THAT
SHOULD BE A PART BE ABLE TO BE A
PART OF THE OVERALL STRATEGY.
I WOULD HOPE.
SO IT WOULD JUST ACCURATE REMARK
ON THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
EXAMPLE.
BECAUSE ONE OF MY A SCIENTISTS
WORKING ON THAT PROJECT AND SHE
WAS VERY.
.
IT IS WAS CONCERNED AFTER THE
RAINS AND THAT WE HAVE SEEN
SOME.
FREE SPROUTING AND.
NATURAL.
GROWTH COMING OUT AND THAT'S
VERY EXCITING THAT'S VERY IT
DOES SEEM TO BE RECOVERING BUT
WE'RE LEARNING WHERE IT RECOVERS
BOUNCED WHICH PLACES MAY BE.
ESSENTIAL REFUGIO THAT WILL
THEN SERVICE SOURCE MATERIAL
FOR.
RECOVERY IN OTHER PLACES SO I'D
SAY THAT THAT SPATIAL MOSAIC AND
THOUGH THE MONITORING THAT WE'RE
DOING IS REALLY INFORMING US ON
THE GROUND. WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
AFTER AN EVENT LIKE THAT WHICH
PLACES ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT?
AND HOW TO HOW DO WE GO FROM
THERE EVEN GIVEN THE INCREASED.
.
VARIABILITY AND BEING ON THE
FRONT LINES.
AND THEN AT LEAST RIGHT BACK TO
THE.
THE FANA DISCUSSION BECAUSE IN
SOME THE ZEAL BAD EELGRASS BEDS
THOUGH CRAP POPULATION CAN TAKE
THE ALGAE OFF WHICH HARMS THEM
THAT'S WHERE THE ORDERS CAME IN
OUR. EATING THE CRABS NOW ORDERS
ARE FLOURISHING YOUR GRASS CAN
FLOURISH THOSE CONNECTIONS HELP
WAS. LEAD TO THE RECOVERY AND
WITHOUT ONE PIECE IN THERE IF WE
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT THEN WE'LL
BE SCRATCHING OUR HEADS ABOUT
WHY IT'S NOT RECOVERING IN THE
WAY WE THOUGHT HE WOULD EXPECT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU BRING UP KANSEN THANK
YOU DATA WILL WILL MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT PANEL.
SO FOR LOCAL PERSPECTIVES AND
SOME OF THOSE PROJECTS.
PROFESSOR
AND THIS NEW CAR CLASS. I SAW
YOU WE WERE PADDLING ON THE
ELKHORN SLOUGH.
THEN AROUND SOME OF THOSE ADDED
VOTE HERE HE FIFTH.
YEAH WITH THE EEL GRASS BEDS IN
THAT.
AND THE ORDERS AND ALL.
OKAY LISA ACTUALLY BEGIN CAN NOT
FIRST I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS ISSUE AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS
AS WELL AS THE REST OF THE SWAT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
.
I WAS THE OTHER THING THAT I
REALLY WANT TO SAY WHICH IS THAT
CLEARLY A TAKE HOME MESSAGE FROM
TODAY IS THAT. EFFORTS TOWARDS
RESTORATION AND CONSERVATION OF
SEAGRASSES ARE DEFINITELY รณ A
WIN WIN SITUATION AND THIS HAS
BEEN RE ITERATED BY SEVERAL
OTHER PEOPLE ALREADY. SO I WILL
JUST.
ADD MY VOTE TO THAT STATEMENT
THAT THERE ARE SO MANY GOOD
REASONS TO RESTORE AND CONSERVE
THESE HABITATS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. AND WHEN WE ADD
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION OR CARBON
SEQUESTRATION ON TOP OF THEM
THAT'S JUST SORT OF AN EXTRA YOU
KNOW BONUS REASON.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO TELL YOU ABOUT?
ARE SOME CURRENT PROJECTS THAT
ARE SUPPORTED BY THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL. THAT SPAN
THE ENTIRE STATE.
.
THESE PROJECTS IN LARGE PART
WERE INSPIRED BY INITIAL WORK
THAT WAS SUPPORTED BY CALIFORNIA
SEAGRAM'S AND SO YOU'LL SORT OF
HERO.
ME SAY THIS A COUPLE TIMES THAT
THESE PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN STATE
AND FEDERAL AGENCIES ARE
ACTUALLY QUITE IMPORTANT IN
UNDERSTANDING QUESTIONS LIKE
THIS.
THE YELLOW DOTS ON THE MAP HERE
TELL YOU PLACES THAT WORST
CURRENTLY TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THESE QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
SEAGRASS MEADOWS. CAN MODIFY
EXTREME CHEMISTRY AND ALSO STORE
CARBON SO WE'RE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND BOTH ASPECTS OF WHAT
THE PREVIOUS PANEL DISCO.
I'D LIKE TO BASICALLY TAKE A
DEEP DIVE INTO TWO OF THESE
SITES AND SO THE FIRST ONE IS
THE HUMBOLDT OCEAN CARBON
OBSERVATORY. THIS IS LED BY JOE
TUBERS  OF CALIFORNIA SEA
GRANT ON IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
SCIENTISTS AT HUMBOLDT STATE
UNIVERSITY AND UC DAVIS I'M ONE
OF THOSE COLLABORATORS.
THIS PROJECT ENCOMPASSES THREE
DIFFERENT GOALS ALL WITHIN
HUMBOLDT BAY AND SO THE FIRST RC
REST SURVEYS WERE SCIENTISTS ARE
GOING OUT REPEATEDLY TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE SEA GRASS. IS
CHANGING SEASONALLY AND THROUGH
TIME AND WERE GOING TO HEAR MORE
FROM SARAH NEWKIRK NEXT ON SORT
OF THE NEXT GENERATION OF HOW WE
MIGHT MONITOR SEAGRASSES LIKE
THAT.
ANOTHER ASPECT OF THIS PROJECT
IS ON A SIGNIFICANT UPGRADE TO
OUR MONITORING SYSTEM IN THIS IN
THE CAT IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION.
UPGRADING OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
MONITORING BOTH THAT TRINIDAD
PIER AND WOOD IN HUMBOLDT BAY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH HOG ISLAND
OYSTER COMPANY.
THIS IS BUILDING UPON A FIVE
YEAR PARTNERSHIP THAT OUR GROUP
AT UC DAVIS HAS HAD WITH HOG
ISLAND OYSTER COMPANY. WE DO
MONITORING JUST LIKE THIS MOLLIS
BAY WHERE IT'S ESSENTIALLY SORT
OF A WEATHER STATION IN THE
OCEAN WHERE WE ARE TRACKING THE
PROCESS OF OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
INSIDE OF THAT DAY. THROUGH TIME
AND WE'VE NOW.
THROUGH THE SOCIAL PROTECTION
COUNCIL SUPPORT BEEN ABLE TO
EXPAND AND PLACE THOSE WEATHER
STATIONS I'M ON THE HUMBOLDT
COAST AND WITHIN THE HUMBOLDT
BAY.
THIS IS ALSO THE STE SITES ARE
SUPPORTED BY THE CENTRAL AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA OCEAN
OBSERVING SYSTEM SO AGAIN WE'RE
SEEING SCIENCE THAT IS BEING
SUPPORTED BY MULTIPLE DIFFERENT
FEDERAL AND STATE PARTNERSHIPS.
FINALLY THIS SITE INCLUDES
MONITORING OF SEAGRASS CHEMISTRY
BOTH WIN IT WOULD IN A SEA GRASS
MEADOW AS WELL AS OUTSIDE WITH
THE REST MEADOW. AND MONITORING
OYSTER GROWTH SO GETTING AT THAT
BIOLOGICAL RESPONSE TO CHANGE.
AND THAT PEACE IS BASICALLY
NESTED WITHIN A MUCH BIGGER
STATEWIDE EFFORT THAT WE HAVE
MADE.
SO WE TELL YOU ABOUT THAT.
SO THAT THAT HUMBOLDT PIECE IS
PART OF.
I'VE A EFFORT THAT WE'VE MADE
TO TRACK THESE PROCESSES WITHIN
SIX DIFFERENT ACTUARIES ACROSS
THE STATE'S ABOUT A DOT A DOZEN
DIFFERENT SEAGRASS MEADOWS ARE
BEING STUDIED.
IN EACH CASE WE PLAY SENSORS
WITH IN THE SEAGRASS BAD AND
OUTSIDE OF THE SEA GRASS BAD.
OFTENTIMES NOT ALWAYS BUT OFTEN
TIMES ALSO WITH OYSTERS.
AND WERE BASICALLY TRACKING HOW
THIS PROCESS OF OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION IS AMELIORATED OR
MODIFIED BY THE SEA GRASS
ITSELF.
WE'RE DOING THIS BOTH IN.
NATURAL OR NATIVE SEAGRASS
MEADOWS AS WELL AS SITES THAT
HAVE BEEN TARGETS FOR
RESTORATION SORE ALSO TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. WHICH OF THESE
TYPES.
RESTORED VERSES NATURAL MEADOWS
MIGHT BE BETTER AT THIS PROCESS
OR ARE THERE WAYS THAT WE COULD
MAXIMIZE.
THE BENEFIT FROM FROM THE
SIMILARITY XIN.
AGAIN I LIKE TO TAKE SORT OF A
DEEP DIVE INTO ONE OF THESE
SITES.
AND NOT IS CYPRESS GROVE INTO
MOLLIS BANG.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE SITE WE
KNOW AND UNDERSTAND THE BEST AT
THIS POINT BECAUSE WE'VE
REPEATEDLY MONITORED IT OVER A
COUPLE OF YEARS NOW.
AND.
A PHD STUDENT.
MELISSA WARD HAS ALSO BUILT A
CO TWO FOX TOWER THAT ACTUALLY
SITS ON SHORE. AND MEASURES THE
CARBON DIOXIDE THAT'S GOING FROM
THE AIR IN TO THE SEA WATER
RIGHT ABOVE THE SEA RESPITE.
SO AT THIS PARTICULAR SITE WE'RE
TRACKING THE FULL PROCESS WERE
WATCHING THE CEO TO GO INTO THE
SEA WATER. WERE WATCHING HOW
THAT CO TWO THEN MOVES THROUGH
AND IS MODIFIED WITHIN THE
SEAGRASS BED.
WITH THOSE.
SENSORS I TOLD YOU ABOUT AND
WE'RE ALSO TAKING SEDIMENT CORES
TO LOOK AT THE SETTLEMENTS.
BELOW THE SEA GRASS BEDS SO AS
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS HAVE MENTIONED
JUST LIKE YOU CAN THINK ABOUT IN
A FOREST WITH SOILS BELOW A
FOREST THERE'S ACTUALLY A LOT OF
CARBON. THAT ENDS UP STORED IN
THOSE SOILS THE SAME THING
HAPPENS IN A SEA GRASS BEDS AND
SO THERE'S A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT.
OF CARBON ORGANIC MATTER THAT
GETS TRAPPED THERE AND IS
PROBABLY TRAPPED FOR DECADES TO
CENTURIES AND WERE ACTUALLY
TRYING TO QUANTIFY THAT PIECE AS
WELL.
SO WHEN WE JUST GIVE YOU A SENSE
OF WHAT WE KNOW SO FAR FROM THIS
SITE IN PARTICULAR.
DURING THE SUMMER SEAGRASS
MEADOWS CAN CHANGE THE WATER
CHEMISTRY UP TO ABOUT POINT ONE
P. H. UNIT.
WHAT I MEAN BY SUMMER IS
ESSENTIALLY THAT SEASON WHERE
THE SEAGRASS MEADOWS ARE QUITE
WASH FROM ABOUT MAY TO OCTOBER?
TO MANY PEOPLE POINT ONE PITCH
UNIT MIGHT SEEM SMALL.
BUT THAT'S ACTUALLY THE SAME
AMOUNT THAT OCEAN CHEMISTRY HAS
CHANGED ALREADY DUE TO HUMAN
IMPACTS TO THE ANTHROPOGENIC
OCEANA CITIZENS URGED OSHA
SUFFOCATION SIGNAL RIGHT NOW. IS
ABOUT POINT ONE PH UNIT.
SO IT'S DEFINITELY A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT THAT THOSE SEA GRASSES
ARE HAVING. DURING THE SUMMER
SO.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE DURING THE
WINTER AND WE'RE STILL TRYING TO
EXPLORE SORT OF WHAT THAT MEANS.
IN THE BIG PICTURE OVER AN
ENTIRE YEAR WITH THAT MEANS.
FOR THE NET IMPACT THE SEA
GRASSES ARE HAVING.
THE OTHER THING THAT WE SEE IS
THAT SETTLEMENTS WITH IN THOSE
SEA GRASS MEADOWS PARTICULARLY
SMALLEST DAY HAVE UP TO ABOUT
TWO TIMES MORE ORGANIC CARBON.
THEN ON VEGETATED HABITATS
THEY DON'T ALWAYS HAVE MORE BUT
IN SOME CASES THEY DO AND SO NOW
THE NEXT STEP IS FOR US TO
IDENTIFY. WHAT ARE THE
CHARACTERISTICS THAT MAKE IT SO
THAT SEE GRASS BEDS ACTUALLY CAN
STORE THAT CARBON FOR DECADES TO
CENTURIES ARE THERE PARTICULAR
MEADOWS THAT MIGHT BE A GOOD
TARGET FOR RESTORATION OR
CONSERVATION? THAT IF WE CAN
IDENTIFY THOSE CHARACTERISTICS
THAT OPTIMIZE THIS PROCESS.
AS I WRAP UP HERE I JUST WANT TO
SORT OF REITERATE A COUPLE OF
THREE THING A COUPLE A COUPLE
THINGS HERE A COUPLE OF THREE
THINGS. AND.
BUT ONE IS THAT WE'VE LEARNED A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT ABOUT THIS IN
A VERY RAPID. UP.
PACE A RAPID.
AMOUNT OF TIME.
I WOULD SAY WERE ON A PRETTY
STEEP TRAJECTORY OF LEARNING
ABOUT BOTH SEAGRASS AND HELP.
IS PLAYING A ROLE IN BOTH OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION AND TO CARBON
SEQUESTRATION.
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE ON THAT
ABOUT STEEP TRAJECTORY WE NEED
TO SORT OF CONTINUE TO ANSWER
THESE KNOWLEDGE GAPS THAT WE'VE
BEEN IDENTIFYING TODAY AND SO I
WILL JUST.
YOU KNOW UNDERSCORE THAT IN THE
STATE INVESTMENT
IN THESE MONITORING AND RESEARCH
EFFORTS HAS BEEN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT IN THAT TRAJECTORY.
THE SECOND THING THAT I WOULD
SAY IS THAT.
.
THIS EVERYTHING I JUST TOLD YOU
ABOUT IS REALLY A STORY THAT HAS
BEEN FACILITATED BY PARTNERSHIPS
AND I ACTUALLY WAS HAPPY THAT I
HEARD AT LEAST TWO OF THE OTHER
SPEAKERS. MENTIONED THE
IMPORTANCE OF PARTNERSHIPS
INCLUDING YOU.
.
SO WHAT YOU HEARD WHAT I JUST
DESCRIBED TO.
.
REFLECTS PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES
UNIVERSITIES CONSERVATION GROUPS
AND VERY IMPORTANTLY THE
SUSTAINABLE AQUACULTURE
COMMUNITY.
AND I WOULD PROPOSE THAT
PARTNERSHIPS LIKE THIS ARE A
MODEL FOR HOW WE SHOULD APPROACH
CLIMATE CHANGE IN THE STATE.
AND HOPEFULLY FEDERALLY IF WE
CAN GET.
THEIR THEIR EAR.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
SPEAKER.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN STONE AND.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
WHO SHOULD BE WATCHING OR
LISTENING.
I'LL START MY REMARKS BY SAYING
AYE TO SORT OF CABINETS ON THE
ODD WOMAN OUT ON THIS PANEL FOR
TWO REASONS ONE IS THAT I'M NOT
A SCIENTIST.
I THE SECOND AND SO YOU'LL HAVE
TO GIVE ALL YOUR HARD QUESTIONS
TO CARRY AND TESSA AYE AT THE
END BUT.
THE SECOND IS THAT MY PROJECT
IS NOT AN OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
PROJECT AYE IT IS NEVER THE LESS
RELEVANT.
WELL I'LL I'LL TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT AND YOU KNOW
I HAVE A VIDEO THAT WILL AYE.
SUPPLEMENT FOR OUT MY FAILURE TO
BE ABLE TO TALK ABOUT IT.
THE OCEAN ACIDIFICATION IS AS
BAD NEWS FOR SHELLFISH AND.
THOUGH SHELLFISH INDUSTRY
RECOGNIZES THAT AND IN
CONSEQUENCE THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND.
OYSTER AQUACULTURE OPERATORS
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES ARE
IN THE PROCESS OF FORMING WHAT
WE'RE CALLING THE. AYE.
I'M SORRY THE SHELLFISH CLIMATE
COALITION WHICH WILL OPERATE AT
THE STATE AND LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL LEVEL ON CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICY. ON THE INDUSTRY IS IS IS
WORRIED ABOUT THE EFFECT OF OUR
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION ON ITS
BOTTOM LINE AND THAT OBVIOUSLY
IS THAT MEANS THAT OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION IS ALSO BAD NEWS
FOR SHELLFISH CONSUMERS.
WE ALL KNOW THAT OYSTERS ARE
DELICIOUS AND WE WANT TO.
CONTINUE TO PRODUCE THEM IN
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA IS IN FACT THE THIRD
LARGEST SHELLFISH CONSUMING
STATE IN THE UNITED STATES UP
BUT IN STATE SHELLFISH
PRODUCTION MEETS LESS THAN HALF
OF THAT DEMAND.
OUR STATE SHELLFISH INDUSTRY
COULD BE SUPPLYING A SUBSTANTIAL
UNSUSTAINABLE LOCAL. I. N.
EXPORT MARKET AND CALIFORNIA
COULD BE LEADING THE NATION AND
MEETING AND EVER GROWING
SHELLFISH DEMAND WHILE CREATING
ENVIRONMENTALLY SUSTAINABLE
LOCAL BLUE JOBS IN COASTAL
COMMUNITIES.
BUT WE'RE CONFLICTED ABOUT THE
GROWTH OF THIS INDUSTRY BECAUSE
WE UNDERSTAND AND UNDERSTOOD
EVEN BEFORE THE MOST RECENT
SCIENCE ON OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE ILL GRASS
HABITAT. OUGHT TO OVERRIDE A
WIDE VARIETY OF SPECIES AND AND
MARRYING SOME OF THE OTHER
PANELISTS ON THE FIRST PANEL.
DETAIL THAT I THINK VERY WELL.
ILL GROUSE IS SUPPOSE COULD
CRITICAL ASTRON HABITAT FOR A
WIDE VARIETY OF MARINE
INVERTEBRATES FISH MAMMALS BIRDS
AS WELL AS NURSERY GROUNDS.
FOR FISH.
THAT ALSO THE ABILITY TO MODIFY
THE SURROUNDING ENVIRONMENT IT'S
AN AYE ECOLOGICAL ENGINEER A
KEEP SETTLEMENTS IN PLACE AND
IMPROVE THE WATER QUALITY. AND
SO THE RECENTLY PUBLICIZED.
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION BENEFIT
MITIGATION SCIENCE IS JUST SORT
OF THE ICING ON ALREADY
VALUABLE.
CAKE.
BUT IT'S GOOD NEWS FOR THE
INDUSTRY IN THE SENSE THAT IT'S.
FINALLY SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
DO ABOUT OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
UNIT WE CAN INCREASE THAT ARE
EXPANSIVE SEA GRASS AND OUR
MEADOWS AND IT HAS BEEN
SOMETHING THAT THEY'VE BEEN
WORRIED ABOUT AND THE REASON
THAT THE INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
WORRIED ABOUT IT IS THAT ILL
GRASS HAS. BEEN UP UNTIL THIS
POINT AND CONTINUES TO BE.
PROBABLY THE.
GREATEST OBSTACLE IN INCREASING.
SHELLFISH GROWING CAPACITY IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ILL GRASS MITIGATION
POLICY OR THE CAMP AND THAT WAS
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE THE HIGHEST
POSSIBLE LEVEL OF PROTECTION. OF
FOR THIS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
HABITAT.
THE POLICY IS ALSO THE MAJOR
ARE LIMITING FACTOR IN THE
PERMITTING PROCESS AT WHICH AS
YOU PROBABLY KNOW. A FROM THE
TIME OF THE COASTAL COMMISSION
CAN TAKE UPWARDS OF EIGHTEEN
MONTHS TO GO FROM.
SERVE THE VISUALIZATION OF AN
OPERATION TO.
ACTUAL OPERATION.
THERE IS OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF THE
CLIENT TO SUPPORT ADVERSE
IMPACTS OF AQUACULTURE ON ILL
GRASS BUT A LOT OF THAT WAS FROM
OUR TRADITIONAL AQUACULTURE
METHODS A LOT OF.
OFTEN INVOLVING PLANTING
OYSTERS ACTUALLY IN THE
SUBSTRATE AND THEN RAKING THEM
UP AND NOT SURPRISINGLY ILL
GRASS DOESN'T LIKE THAT KIND OF
THING.
AND SO ON THE OTHER HAND WE
ALSO HAVE ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE
FROM OUR INDUSTRY PARTNERS THAT
ARE PROPERLY SPACED HANGING
BASKETS AND LONG LINES. AYE HAS
LESS IMPACT AND MAY EVEN HAVE A
POSITIVE IMPACT ON ILL GRASS
GROWTH.
SO THERE IS A CONSIDERABLE VOID
OUR KNOWLEDGE OF THESE SERVE
NOVEL AQUACULTURE METHODS ON.
THE AQUACULTURE EELGRASS
INTERACTIONS AND IN CONSEQUENCE
WE'VE PUT TOGETHER AN
INTERDISCIPLINARY TEAM FROM THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY. UC SANTA
CRUZ ACTUALLY ONE OF TESSA'S OF
FORMER OPPOSE STOCKS AS IS
LEADING THIS EFFORT FOR UC SANTA
CRUZ AND THE HOG ISLAND OYSTER
COMPANY AND I WANNA JUST
IDENTIFY TERRY SAWYER WHO'S
HERE.
FROM.
FROM THAT COMPANYAND WE'RE
ASSESSING HILL GROUSED
AQUACULTURE INTERACTIONS ON
ACTUALLY USING DRONES WILL BE
ABLE TO SEE SOME OF THE FOOTAGE
FROM.
FROM THE VIDEO COMING UP.
WE BELIEVE THAT BY DEVELOPING
COST EFFECTIVE MONITORING
APPROACHES TO SURVEY ILL GRASS
SORT OF IN SITU WE CAN ALLOW THE
AQUACULTURE INDUSTRY AND
REGULATORY AGENCIES TO PROVIDE
HIGH QUALITY. AQUACULTURE
PRODUCTS WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY.
PROTECTING THE ECOLOGICAL
COMPONENTS.
THAT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT SO
ONCE THE MONITORING PROTOCOLS
BEEN TESTED AND VALIDATED WE
INTEND TO HAND OFF TO THE
INDUSTRY ITSELF. SO THEY CAN BE
WHEN THEY'RE OUT THERE IN THEIR
FIELDS THEY CAN BE MONITORING
THEIR OWN IMPACTS ON. ON ILL
GRASS AND THIS WILL I THINK.
AYE EXPONENTIALLY INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY OF DATA ON NOT JUST
THE HEALTH OF YOUR GRASS AND IT.
TOOK PARTICULAR AND.
ESTUARY BUT ALSO UP PROVIDE A
LOT OF THIS.
CERTAIN OBSERVATIONAL
INFORMATION ON PROTOCOL WILL
REALLY HELP TO
UNDERSTAND THESE INTERACTIONS
STATEWIDE AND I IT'S IT'S WORTH
SAYING ESPECIALLY WITH REFERENCE
TO.
THE THE. INFORMATION ON THE DIE
OFF IN SAN FRANCISCO BAY AS
PERTAINS TO.
LAST LAST WINTER'S RAINFALL.
THOSE MONITORING WITH DRONES
BECAUSE IT IS SO CHEAP AND
ACCURATE WILL ALLOW US TO GET A
TEMPORAL RESOLUTION ON SORT OF
THE INNER SEASONAL VARIATION
AND.
EELGRASS EXTENT THAT WE'RE NOT
WE'RE JUST SIMPLY NOT ABLE TO
GET BY SENDING DIVERS DOWN THERE
THEY JUST AREN'T UNWILLING TO
ARE UNABLE TO.
GO DOWN AS OFTEN AS WE NEED TO
GET THAT KIND OF TEMPORAL
RESOLUTION. I'M SO WE'RE REALLY
HOPING THAT THIS.
HONORING PROTOCOL WILL REALLY
INCREASE OUR SCIENTIFIC
KNOWLEDGE.
I'M SO IN SOME THE INDUSTRY
KNOWS BETTER THAN ANYBODY THAT
HEALTHY ILL GRASS MEANS MORE
OYSTERS AND AN IMPROVED BOTTOM
LINE. AND WITH THAT I GUESS I
WOULD ASK YOU TO PLAY THIS
LITTLE INFORMATIONAL VIDEO THAT
WE'VE PRODUCED.
NNOVA.
THIS.
CHOOSE BECOMING ANY
SILLY IMPORTANT GLOBAL SHOULD
SORT.
AND WITH THIS GROWTH COMES
URGENT UNANSWERED.
THE INTERACTION.
OPERATIONS BOTH POSITIVE AND
NEGATIVE WITH OUR EGOS.
AT THE NATURE CONSERVANCY WE ARE
FOCUSING ON ADDRESSING MANY OF
THESE IN PART
BY BRINGING TOGETHER SO
TESTS AND INDUSTRY AND TOMORROW
THEY CALIFORNIA
RIGHT AND CENTER
SUPPOSE BACKYARD.
MONITOR ONE PARTICULAR EGOS.
GIL GRASS
THE.
IS IN
PARDON
IN ASTRI.
BECAUSE.
SO IT'S HOMES FOR
A LOT OF INVERTEBRATES.
FISH.
A NURSERY HABITAT
FOR JUVENILE STAGES OF FISH
INCLUDING SOME
FULL IMPORTANT.
HE'S.
STILL PARADIGM IS.
CULTURE ACT
THIS.
I'M STILL TO SEE GASES HOWEVER
UP PARTNERS AT HOMETOWN LISTA
COMPANIES HAVE.
OBSERVE THAT
SOME INSTANCES THE HILL GRASS
THAT.
SO THERE AQUACULTURE TERRIBLE
EXPAND INTO THEIR LEASES AND
GROW IN AND AROUND.
YEAR.
WE THE FUNNY SELFISH
S. LOCATIONS
STAY FOR
JUST ABOUT
FIVE YEARS.
AND I'M A BIG BELIEVER IN THAT
IS AMONG THE MOST SUSTAINABLE
WAYS TO TO GROW ANIMAL PROTEIN.
THE PRIMARY IS FOR DOING AT ALL
IN THESE IN YOUR SHORT FIREMAN.
WHICH IS WHERE HE'S RESOURCES
LIKE YOUR GLASS ARE.
BEING IN A BUSINESS WHERE YOU
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HIM.
WHAT WERE ABOUT
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THAT USING
SCIENCE IS REALLY AN IMPORTANT
PART?
WE'VE SEEN CHANGES OUT HERE IN
THE SAY OVER THE PAST THIRTY
YEARS.
WE'VE SEEN THE GROWTH IN THE THE
EXPANSION OF THE REAL GRASS BEDS
WE A BUFFER AREAS THAT ALL THE
SUDDEN THE ADDRESSES MOVED IN.
WE HAVE QUESTIONS WE HAVE THAT
NEED TO BE ANSWERED OVER TIME.
WHAT ARE?
WHAT ARE THE DEBT?
THE NEGATIVE.
TO HAVE A TOOL DEVELOPED THAT IS
COST EFFECTIVE ENOUGH THE
GROWERS GENERAL CAN USE.
WOULD BE. USING BENEFICIAL BUT
THERE'S. UNCERTAINTY.
AROUND SOMEBODY
ENVIRONMENTAL INTERACTIONS
AND I WANT TO UNDERSTAND THIS.
I UNDERSTAND OUR AFFECTS
NEGATIVE POSITIVE.
THIS IS SUCH A GREAT STUDY
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO HELP US
ANSWER SOME OF THESE QUESTIONS
HOPEFULLY NOT JUST LOST PAYMENT
BAY IS ALL AROUND US.
ANSWER THESE.
OUR TEAM IS LAUNCHING DRONES
DIRECTLY OVER HIGH
ISLAND OYSTER.
FARMING OPERATIONS
MONITOR THE GROWTH APPEAL
GROUND.
PROVEN TO BE EFFECTIVE.
S. MONITORING TOOL IN THE HANDS
OF
FARMERS ALLOWING THE ON.
INDUSTRY.
VALUABLE CAN.
FORMATION.
ILL GRAB.
OPERATION.
THE RESEARCHERS AT UC SANTA
CRUZ.
TELL BROWN.
TERMINATION.
WHERE THE YOU'LL GRAB?
THAT WE CAN USE THAT
TWO FIVE.
IN OTHER IN.
BEING THAT WE'VE RECOVERING A
LITTLE BIT LARGER AREA.
GO ON FROM MULTIPLE YEARS CAN.
THAT I THINK.
NOW THAT ONLY OVER THE YEARS
IN TALKING TO THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY
NEVER DID UNDERSTAND IT THAT WAS
IMPORTANT IN THE BUILDING DID
HONEST
OPUS.
DEVELOP A STUDY FINE I COULD
PARTNERS
AND LOOK AT THIS ISSUE IN THAT
REALM.
AND HOPEFULLY DEVELOPMENT THAT
WILL HELP ANSWER SOME QUESTIONS.
THIS THING IS WE ARE THE BEST
PARTNERS
WE GET THIS DATA BECAUSE WE'RE
OUT OF ALL THE TIME.
AND WE SHOULD KNOW
WANT TO KNOW ABOUT WHAT'S GOING.
I FEEL AS IF YOU WILL.
SO TO ME THIS IS.
WHAT'S REALLY EXCITING ABOUT
THE.
THE NEED FOR THIS TYPE OF
RESEARCH TO FILL GAPS IN OUR
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT YOUR GRASS
CULTURE INTERACTIONS HAS NEVER
BEEN MORE URGENT.
COLLABORATIVE PROJECTS THAT
UNITE INDUSTRY.
SCIENTISTS
AND NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
THE POTENTIAL TO HELP PROMOTE
HEALTHY EGOS.
AND CHANGE THE WAY WE SURPRISE
SUSTAINABLE SEAFOOD FROM
.
I THINK.
I THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE FOR THE INVITATION.
IT'S.
IT'S REALLY PLEASURE TO BE HERE
TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
RESEARCH THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING
ON AND I JUST FIRST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT.
.
ALL TALK ABOUT SOME WORK THAT
I'VE BEEN DOING IN COLLABORATION
WITH A LOT OF DIFFERENT PEOPLE
SO THERE'S MANY SCIENTISTS THAT
WORK ON THAT'S I'M I MAKE HOUSE
IN NORTHRIDGE THEIR SCIENTISTS
PRIME STANFORD UNIVERSITY
HOPKINS MARINE STATION AT UC
DAVIS AND WE ALSO HAVE PARTNERS
WITH THE BAY FOUNDATION. WHICH
TO ENTER INTO THE MICROPHONE
BEGIN HERE AND FOR THE RECORD
YET SO WE HAVE.
ALSO HAVE A PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE BAY FOUNDATION WHICH IS.
ANOTHER ORGANIZATION THAT'S
BEEN MENTIONED I MANY TIMES
ALREADY SO ALL BEACH SORT OF
CHANGING THE FOCUS FROM
SEAGRASSES OVER TO HELP.
SO I'LL TELL YOU ABOUT SOME
RESULTS WE HAVE SOME FROM
CURRENT PROJECTS OF THE FIRST
PROJECTS IS THAT IT WAS REALLY
THIS BASELINE DATA OF SEA WATER
CHEMISTRY NICK HELP FOREST AND.
THIS REALLY STARTED OFF AS A
SIDE PROJECT THAT HAD NO FUNDING
BEHIND IT AND WE WERE ABLE TO
JUST COBBLE TOGETHER PEOPLE THAT
YOU KNOW WERE INTERESTED IN THE
STATE. AND NOT SOME SOME WORK
THAT HAS BEEN PUBLISHED THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON AND THEN THESE
TWO OTHER STUDIES.
KIND OF CAME OUT OF THAT DOT IS
FIRST SORT OF EFFORT BECAUSE
PEOPLE REALLY INTEREST IN THESE
QUESTIONS BUT THERE WAS REALLY
NO INFORMATION AVAILABLE ABOUT.
CUT FORESTS AND THEIR POTENTIAL
TO MILITARY WATER CHEMISTRY.
SO FOLLOWING UP ON THAT NOW I'M
WE HAVE FUNDING FROM THE
NATIONAL SCIENCE FOUNDATION TO
DO A REALLY MECHANISTIC STUDY TO
QUANTIFY RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN.
HOW BIG THE CULT FOREST IS WHAT
THE OCEANOGRAPHY LOOKS LIKE IN
THE AREA AND THEN THE IMPACT ON
THE SEA WATER CHEMISTRY AND? WE
REALLY WON'T BE ABLE TO TELL YOU
WHERE OR WHEN AND SO WE
UNDERSTAND THOSE MECHANISMS AND
THE SORT OF INTERPLAY BETWEEN
THOSE DIFFERENT I'M FACTORS.
AND THEN LASTLY I'M THIS UP IN
THIS NEW PROJECT THAT STARTING
WITH.
THAT'S FUNDED BY U. S. CITIES
SEE GRANT PROGRAM WE'RE LOOKING
AT RESTORATION STATES THAT THE
BAY FOUNDATION ARE DOING SO SO
THE CALPERS FRUSTRATION IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW TO GOING INTO THOSE
URCHIN PARENTS AND MANUALLY
REMOVING HER CHANCEL THOSE
URCHINS ARE THERE BECAUSE OF
LIKE YOU MENTIONED EARLIER THAT
THE IMPORTANCE OF THINKING OF
THE LANCE THE INTERFACE BECAUSE.
THE REASON NOT THAT URCHINS WERE
ABLE TO REALLY GET A STRONGHOLD
WAS BECAUSE OF POLLUTION AND
OTHER SORT OF MULTIPLE STRESSORS
THAT WERE OCCURRING.
AND SO NOW IS THAT SOME OF THE
STRESSES ARE REMOVED I'M YOU
KNOW THEY'RE GOING THROUGH THE
REMOVING OUR CHANCE AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT AS THIS CULT IS
COMING IN. WERE INVOLVED IN THAT
THE EFFORT.
THAT.
I'M WAS MENTIONED EARLIER WITH
THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY LOOKING
AT THE POTENTIAL FOR WAVE
ATTENUATION OF CULT FOREST WHICH
WOULD BE THIS ADDITIONAL
ECOSYSTEM SERVICE ON TOP OF ALL
THE OTHER ECOSYSTEM SERVICES
THEY RD PROVIDE. AND THE NOW
WE'RE FINALLY GONNA START SEEING
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU HAVE A
HABITAT THAT WAS DEVOID OF KELP
WHAT THAT CHEMISTRY LOOK LIKE
AND THEN WHAT IS THE CHEMISTRY
LOOK LIKE ONCE WE HAVE A HEALTHY
CUP FORCE THAT'S GROWING SO. WE
NOW HAVE FUNDING TO LOOK AT THAT
AS WELL.
SO FIRST I JUST WANTED TO YOU
KNOW SORT OF REMIND US ALL WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO BE IN A CUP FOREST
IF YOU'VE BEEN IN A CULT FOREST.
AND SO YOU KNOW MOST OF THE
BIOMASS IS THAT THE SURFACE SO
THEY HAVE THESE MASSIVE CANOPY
IS THAT YOU CAN SEE FROM
SATELLITE IMAGES WHICH ARE
REALLY HANDY IN TERMS OF MAPPING
THE DISTRIBUTIONS OF COUPLE ON
THE COAST OF CALIFORNIA. AND THE
PHYSICAL STRUCTURE OF THE CULT
IS ALTERING THE HABITAT AND IT'S
CHANGING THE WAY IT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGING THE WAY
THE WATER MOVES IN THIS AREA
BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE A SOLID
OBJECT AND WATER MOVING RIGHT.
IT CAN'T GO THROUGH THE SOLID
OBJECTS IT'S EITHER GONNA HAVE
TO GO AROUND HER OR DO SOMETHING
OR SLOW DOWN TO GO THROUGH THOSE
AREAS AND SO THERE'S SOME REALLY
INTERESTING FEEDBACKS BETWEEN
THAT HELP ITSELF. AND THE
PHYSICAL ENVIRONMENT WHICH IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND HOW MUCH
POTENTIAL YOU HAVE TO MODIFY THE
WATER COLUMN.
BUT THEY'RE STILL YOU KNOW A LOT
OF BIOMASS THAT'S UNDER WATER AS
WELL AND IT YOU KNOW JUST
FURTHER ADDS TO THIS IDEA THAT
THERE'S THIS PHYSICAL STRUCTURE
THAT'S THROUGHOUT THE WATER
COLUMN YOU KNOW FROM THIRTY TO
FIFTY FEET THAT. IS ALSO
IMPACTING ON THESE HABITATS AND
REALLY INTERESTING WAYS AND SO
ARE SORT OF TAKE ON THIS IS TO
MEASURE ALL OF THOSE THINGS
REALLY GET A HANDLE ON THE
OCEANOGRAPHY. ON WHAT THAT HELP
IS DOING AND THE CHEMISTRY.
SO HERE'S I'M SOME OF WHAT WE
KNOW SO FAR TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION ABOUT IF HOPE FOR ITS
CAN USED AS A MANAGEMENT TOOL TO
MITIGATE XIN ACIDIFICATION. SO
THERE DEFINITELY IS SOME
POTENTIAL FOR HELP AND THERE'S
SOME INDICATION THAT CALPERS
LOCALLY RAISE P. H..
.
IN IN SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
TIME SERIOUS FROM THIS WORK THAT
WE DID WHICH WAS I'M SAMPLING
OVER THE COURSE OF THE YEAR. AYE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE THAT HELP FOREST OF UP
TO ZERO POINT FIVE PEACH UNITS
AT TIMES AND ALSO THERE'S A
REALLY INTERESTING VERTICAL
GRADIENT SO. I'M.
AT THE SURFACE THE BEAT THE
PEACH AS HIGH AS WHICH MAKES
SENSE BECAUSE THAT'S AGAIN OR
MOST OF THIS CULT MATERIAL IS
LOCATED.
AND THEN AT THE BOTTOM THAT
PEACH WITH HIGHEST AT A SITE
WITH LOW WAVE ACTIVITIES SO WE
LOOK TO SI.
THIS BIG HELP FOR US IN FRONT
OF HOPKINS MARINE STATION NEXT
THE MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM. AND
THE SITE THAT WAS MORE WE'VE
PROTECTED HIDE A BIGGER
DIFFERENCE INSIDE AND OUTSIDE
BUT THE SITE THAT HAD MORE WE'VE
EXPOSURE THERE SO MUCH WATER
MOTION THAT IT BASICALLY JUST
GOT SPLASHED OUT THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH TIME AT THE BOTTOM. FOR
THAT HELP TO REALLY MAKE ANY
KIND OF AN IMPACT
AND WE HAVE SOME PRELIMINARY
DATA THAT WAS I'M TAKEN IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THIS EFFORT
WITH ON THE BAY FOUNDATION AND A
PHD STUDENT CRESCENT ELSEWHERE
FROM UC DAVIS.
AT THIS CUP FOREST RESTORATION
SITE WHERE.
WE TOOK SOME.
DODD SOME CHEMISTRY DATA AND YOU
CAN SEE FROM THIS POT THAT THESE
THESE BROWN MARKS ARE SHOWING.
THAT HELP ABUNDANCE THERE TIME
AND SO SHOWING THAT YOU NOTED
THAT IN THE BEGINNING OF THE
RESTORATION THEY REMOVED URCHINS
THEY KNOW THE COP WASN'T THERE
AND THEN THE CULT STARTED COMING
IN. AND WE SAMPLED SOME OF THE
CHEMISTRY AND I WAS THE COP
STARTED GROWING AND WE
DEFINITELY SAW IT THIS INCREASE
IN PH THE WILL BE. GOING BACK TO
SOME OF THE SIGHTS AND AN
ADDITIONAL RESTORATION SITES TO
COLLECT. MORE DATA.
SO THAT'S YOU KNOW SORT OF WHERE
WE'RE AT NOW BUT WE STILL HAVE A
LOT OF TIME QUESTIONS AND WE'RE
WORKING ON SOME STUFF THAT I
THINK WILL REALLY ALLOW US TO
ADVANCE THE ANSWERS TO THIS
QUESTION OVER THE NEXT TWO TO
THREE YEARS.
SO FIRST YOU KNOW UNDER WHAT
CONDITIONS SHOULD WE EXPECT A
CULT FOREST EFFECT ON CHEMISTRY
SO WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
QUANTIFY MECHANISTICALLY THE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN. CUT FOR A
SITE IS THE LOCAL LOCAL
OCEANOGRAPHY AND THE SEA WATER
CHEMISTRY AND NOT YOU KNOW IS
REALLY GONNA ALLOW US TO SEE. IN
THIS PARTICULAR HABITAT THAT HAS
THIS SORT OF WAVE ENVIRONMENT
YES LIKE WE WOULD EXPECT TO SEE
IN A FACT OR MAYBE NO WE
WOULDN'T EXPECT ISSUE THAT
AFFECTS THAT'S THAT'S REALLY THE
BIG GOAL. I MEAN WILL BE
COLLECTING DATA.
THIS SUMMER AND MODERATE A
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT SITES AND THE
NEXT SUMMER I'M AS WELL AND
WE'RE SORT OF TARGETING THE TIME
WHEN WE KNOW THE CULPRIT OF IS
THE HIGHEST WILL BE WHAT
EXPECTANCY A DIFFERENCE. BECAUSE
DURING WINNER WHEN THE COPS
ENOUGH SAYS THERE REALLY ISN'T
ANY DIFFERENCE INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE BECAUSE THAT HELP IS AT
SUCH A LOW DENSITY BUT WILL BE
ABLE TO SORT OF PUT SOME.
YOU KNOW BOUNDS ON THOSE TYPES
OF RELATIONSHIPS.
AND HEN YOU KNOW THE NEXT
QUESTION IS CUT FOREST
RESTORATION LEAD TO A CHANGE IN
SEA WATER CHEMISTRY SERVICES
WORK WILL BE DOING OVER THE NEXT
YEAR WE'RE GONNA MEASURE CHANGES
IN SEA WATER CHEMISTRY WHEN HIS
CUP FORESTS ARE RESTORED. SO
THAT PROJECT IS STARTING RIGHT
NOW BOTH OF THESE PROJECTS ARE
STARTING RIGHT NOW AND SO YOU
KNOW REALLY WILL BE ABLE TO KNOW
SOME THINGS I'M I THINK PRETTY
SOON WITHIN THE NEXT. TWO TO
THREE YEARS I MEAN WE ARE ABLE
THAT TO DO SOME SOME GOOD WORK
WITH WITHOUT FUNDING AND I'M
EXCITED THAT NOW WE HAVE FUNDING
FROM THE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL BE ABLE TO YOU
I'M REALLY ADVANCE OUR KNOWLEDGE
ON THESE TOPICS.
AND THEN YOU KNOW WHERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZE PROTECTION AND
RESTORATION LOTS OF COURSE THIS
BIG QUESTION THAT PEOPLE WANT TO
KNOW AND AND FROM RESULTS OF
THESE TWO STUDIES. WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PREDICT WHEN AND WHERE
HELP FOREST'S WILL HAVE AN
IMPACT ON CHEMISTRY AND SO AGAIN
I THINK ABOUT THAT THE SORT OF
END OF THE DATA COLLECTION BASIN
AS WERE TRYING TO PUT ALL THE
PIECES TOGETHER. HOPEFULLY
WITHIN THE NEXT TWO THREE YEARS
WILL HAVE SOME ANSWERS FOR YOU.
SO IMPORTANT NEXT STEPS.
ONE OF THE THINGS.
BUT MOST BUT NOT. ALL.
OKAY SO SO I GUESS THAT AFTER
MECHANISTIC STUDIES WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PRIORITIZE THE IT'S AND.
AND THIS THE REALLY COOL THING
ABOUT HELP IS THAT.
IT THERE'S A LOT OF WORK DONE
ON MAPPING ALREADY AND BECAUSE
YOU CAN SEEK HELP AND SATELLITES
THERE'S THIS WHOLE TEAM OF
PEOPLE I'M LED BY TOM BELL AYE
AYE UC SANTA BARBARA AND KYLE
CAVANAUGH AT UCLA. WHERE THEY
HAVE REALLY DONE THE WORK AND
THEY CAN GO BACK TO THE EIGHTIES
LOOKING AT HISTORICAL SATELLITE
IMAGES AND COME OUT ALL OF THE
CULT FORESTS THAT WERE ALONG
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ARE NOW
EXPANDING IT UP ALONG THE WHOLE
WEST COAST OF THE U. S.?
AND TOM AS A COLLABORATOR ON ON
THE WORK THAT IDEAL AND SO WE
WILL BE ABLE TO AND THEY CAN
ALSO LOOK AT WHICH CUT FOR US
HAVE BEEN THE MOST PERSISTENT
WHICH I THINK IS ANOTHER BIG
PIECE OF THIS PUZZLE OF WHICH
ONES YOU MIGHT WANT TO
PRIORITIZE. FOR PROTECTION AND
RESTORATION SO.
SO IN YOU KNOW THINKING ABOUT
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE MAPPING IT
THERE'S UP I THINK A REALLY BIG
POTENTIAL HAD. TIME TO DO SOME
GOOD WORK IN THE FUTURE.
AND THEN THERE'S.
A LOT OF PROJECTS COMING ON
BOARD I'M SURE YOU KNOW ABOUT
THERE'S ARTIFICIAL REEFS GOING
AND AND THE USER ACTUALLY REALLY
GREAT OPPORTUNITIES TO COLLECT
SIMILAR DATA TO THAT THAT WERE
ALREADY COLLECTING. SO THAT WE
CAN YOU KNOW.
SAMPLE MORE AND MORE SITES AT
THAT THIS POINT IT'S IT'S A
LIMITATION OF YOU KNOW WE CAN'T
BE IN ALL OF THESE PLACES AT
ONCE AND SO TRYING TO SAMPLE AS
MANY SITES AS POSSIBLE. TO
REALLY FILL OUT THAT SPACE TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE AND WHEN WE
SHOULD EXPECT TO SEE AN
EFFECTIVE HELP ON THAT WATER CON
CHEMISTRY.
SO I THINK MOVING FORWARD
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE STATE. AND
THEN LASTLY THERE'S REALLY I
AGREE EFFORTS GOING ON IN OTHER
STE AND OTHER STATES AND EVEN
JUST PREPARING TO BE HERE TODAY
I SPOKE WITH. PEOPLE OUT I'M
FROM WASHINGTON STATE WHO ARE
THEY RIGHT NOW HAVE A TWO AND A
HALF ACRE.
CULT AQUACULTURE CITE SUGAR
CULT AND THEY HAVE THEIR IT'S A
COLLABORATION WITH.
AQUACULTURE WITH.
.
STATE AGENCIES WITH FEDERAL
AGENCIES WITH NO I AS WELL AS
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
WASHINGTON AND SO THEY'RE
LOOKING AT THIS THEY'RE LOOKING
AT SUGAR CULT WHICH IS NOT.
CANOPY FORMING SPECIES LIKE
MACRO CISTUS.
THAT THE GIANT HELP OR THE BOOK
HEALTH.
SO IT'S IT'S BASICALLY JUST
LIKE ONE LIKE LONG BLADE BUT
THEY'RE GROWING IT ON LINES AND
THEY'RE LOOKING AT WHAT HAPPENS
WITH THE OCEANOGRAPHY IN THE
AREA WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE WATER
CHEMISTRY AS WELL AS USES OF THE
KELP AND TRYING TO SEE IF
THERE'S. A WAY THAT THEY COULD
BE GROWING MISC HELP THAT THAT
WE COULD BRING IT ON LAND AND
USED FOR FERTILIZER OR AN ANIMAL
FEED FOR FOR AGRICULTURE SO.
THEY'RE REALLY TRYING TO TAKE A
HOLISTIC VIEW OF WHAT DESK HELP
AQUACULTURE I'M IMPACT COULD
HAVE SO WE HAVE NOW BEGUN SORT
OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT SHARING
YOU KNOW.
TRYING TO COMPARE DATA SETS
THINKING ABOUT DIFFERENT SPECIES
AND SORT OF THE BENEFITS THAT
THEY.
THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE DIFFERENT
SUBSPECIES AND THEN OF COURSE WE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD WITH I MEAN
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THESE QUESTIONS FOR BALK
HELPS ALL THE WORK THAT I'VE
BEEN DOING IS ON GIANT CULT IN
CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND.
BOOK HELP IS.
YOU KNOW KIND OF A DIFFERENT
BEAST THAN.
THAN GIANT KELP BUT YOU KNOW
THAT'S I THINK ANOTHER BIG NEXT
STEP IS TO TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
AN ADDED SPECIALLY WITH THE LOSS
OF OF BOOK HEALTH IS.
ANSWERING SIMILAR SORTS OF
QUESTIONS
SO I I GUESS.
YEAH I'LL JUST AND BY YOU KNOW
THINKING YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND I THINK WE HAVE
A LOT OF I'M REALLY EXCITING
PROJECTS.
COMING UP AND THERE'S A LOT OF
MOMENTUM ON THIS AND.
IT'S IT'S A REALLY GOOD TIMES
YOU I'M.
TO BE ADDRESSING THESE
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
DOZEN GO WITHOUT NOTICE THAT
FUNDING NEEDED YEAH BUT THE
COUPLE POINTS THERE THAT'S.
THAT'S THAT'S REALLY GOOD.
UP WITH WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
I JUST RAN INTO ONE OF THE
PRINCIPLES THAT A COMPANY AND I
DON'T MEMBER THE COMPANY'S NAME
BUT THE WEBSITE IS PLANET DOT
COM.
THEY HAVE PUT INTO ORBIT.
A NUMBER OF LOWER EARTH ORBIT.
POLAR SATELLITES
SO AS THE EARTH SPINS UNDERNEATH
IT THEY LITERALLY GET.
AS AS LIFE BY LINE IMAGE OF THE
ENTIRE PLANET EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND THE DATE IS AVAILABLE THERE.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT LOOKING TO
TALK TO FOLKS WHO INTEREST IN
THIS TO FIGURE OUT WHAT CENTERS
IT'S ALL OPTICAL SENSORS NOW
WHAT OTHER SENSORS THEY CAN PUT
UP. SIDE OF THAT IS A RESOURCE
THAT YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH I JUST
LEARNED ABOUT IT BUT WHAT AN
INCREDIBLE.
RESOURCE THAT THEY'RE MAKING
THAT DATA AVAILABLE.
TO ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO TO USE
IT IN THIS COULD BE VERY VERY
VALLEY WITH IF THEY'RE VERY JUST
SIT AND.
COLLECTING THAT DATA THROUGH THE
DATA FROM UNDERSTANDING CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE BUT THAT'S
THAT'S QUITE A RESOURCE LOOK AT
THE DRONE FOOTAGE AND AND. HOW
WE MONITOR AND MANAGE AND ALL
THE IMAGES OF OF KELP BEDS SORT
OF FOOD THAT FLUCTUATING AROUND
THE BECAUSE? THAT'S A REALLY
GOOD.
RESOURCE POTENTIALLY SO IF YOU
HADN'T HEARD ABOUT THAT.
AND FOR.
THIS NEW QUIRK THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE I
THINK EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM.
WOULD SAY WE'VE GOT TO RESTORE
BECAUSE THAT'S THE RIGHT THING
TO DO.
BUT FOR A LOT OF OTHERS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ECONOMIC BENEFIT
OF WHY ELSEWHERE RESTORING OF
COURSE.
LOVE THE OYSTERS FROM HOG ISLAND
AND OTHERS.
BUT THAT'S HIGH IN AQUACULTURE
AND THAT'S WHY SEATS YOU WILL BE
AT THE AIRPORT AT.
.
SO IT MUST MANY MARINE LAB
THEY'VE GOT UP THERE A
BURGEONING. AQUACULTURE PROGRAM
THERE THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
FEED INTO THE AQUACULTURE
INDUSTRY AND AND REALLY GROW THE
CAPACITY IN CALIFORNIA.
TO TRAIN PEOPLE TO LEARN ABOUT
IT SO THAT WE CAN DEVELOP AND
AQUACULTURE INDUSTRY AND HAVING
THE ECONOMIC BASIS FOR THIS WORK
AS WELL AS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
BASIS
IT'S WORK. THOSE PARTNERSHIPS
TRULY I THINK ARE IMPORTANT.
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING IN THAT HOG ISLAND OTHERS
ARE DOING.
TO HELP US UNDERSTAND THE.
THE IMPLICATIONS BUT ONE THING
THAT STRUCK ME.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE TAMALES BAY.
KNOWING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT OF
COURSE THAT HUMBLE BAY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE THE FRESH
WATER FLUSHING THROUGH SERVICES
GO BACK.
EACH OF THOSE HAVE VERY VERY
DIFFERENT CHARACTERISTICS ABOUT
TITLE FLOW CURRENT INTO MOLLIS
PAGES SORT OF CATCHES ALL OF
THAT.
NORTH SOUTH CURRENT.
ALONG THE COAST AND SO DOESN'T
FLUSH THE SAME WAY THAT SOME OF
THE OTHER BAYS ARE HOW IMPORTANT
IS THAT IN.
THE INVESTIGATIONS AND AND ARE
YOU LOOKING AT. THE DIFFERENT
CHARACTERISTICS OF THESE PLACES.
OR IS THIS STILL EARLY ENOUGH
THAT THAT'S.
SO IT IS NOT BE LOOKED AT YEAH
ABSOLUTELY SIR THAT IS WAS A
FUNDAMENTAL GOAL OF THAT
EXPANSION TO ALL SIX OF THOSE
SITES SO WE STARTED IN BODEGA
AND SMALLEST BANG A. ORIGINALLY
AND THEN WE'VE MOVED STATEWIDE
IN PART OF IN PART DUE TO THE
OBSERVATION THAT YOU JUST MADE
WHICH IS THAT EACH OF THESE
ACTUARIES. REALLY FUNCTION
DIFFERENTLY AN EVEN SITES WITH
IN ACTUARIES BEHAVE DIFFERENTLY
SO I WOULD SAY THE SITES THAT
WERE MONITORING WITHIN SMALLEST
BAY. IF YOU'RE OUT TOWARDS THE
MOUTH THREE YOU'RE GETTING A LOT
OF OCEANOGRAPHIC INFLUENCE WE
SEE SOME DIFFERENT PATTERNS AND
CHARACTERISTICS THAN WE DO IN
SEA GRASS MEADOWS THAT ARE MORE
IN THE INTERIOR OF THE BAY. AND
SO ALONG WITH THOSE.
SENSORS FOR OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
WE ALSO PUT SENSORS THAT
ACTUALLY MONITOR THE FLOW OF THE
WATER THROUGH THE SEA GRASS
MEADOW. AND SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
DOCTOR NICHOLS WAS BROUGHT UP
ABOUT WHEN WATER COMES UP
AGAINST THE SEAGRASS MEADOW IS
IT SLOWING AND AS IT MOVES TO
THE SEA GRASS MEADOW OR IS IT
MOVING AROUND THE EDGES. AND ARE
THOSE BEHAVIORS DIFFERENT AT
DIFFERENT SITES WITHIN AN
ACTUARY ARE THEY DIFFERENT MORE
BROADLY ACROSS THE STATE IN
DIFFERENT ACTUARIES. AND WE
WOULD LOVE TO ANSWER ALL OF THAT
AND THAT'S THOSE ARE SOME BIG
QUESTIONS.
WOULD PROBABLY CAN'T ANSWER IT
IMMEDIATELY BUT YES THAT'S OF
THE DESIGN OF THE STUDY WAS
ABSOLUTELY TO GET AT SOME OF
THOSE DIFFERENCES OKAY OKAY WELL
THAT'S GOOD BECAUSE IT'S JUST.
WHAT LITTLE I KNOW ABOUT SOME OF
SAID YES AND I KNOW THAT THEY?
THAT THEY DO FUNCTIONAL LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENTLY AND THEN.
AND DOCTOR YOU ALSO MENTIONED
YOU OFFER PUT SEAGRASS.
WITH OYSTERS. AND IS THAT SAID
THAT YOU CAN.
SEE ABOUT THAT THE GROWTH OF THE
OYSTERS YET OR OTHER SO WE ARE
TRYING TO MONITOR.
GROWTH RATE CHANGES WITH THE
OYSTERS IF THEY'RE INSIDE VERSUS
OUTSIDE OF THE SEAGRASS MEADOWS
AND THOUGHT THAT PROJECT IS
BEING LED BY CHRISTY CROKER WHO
IS THE COLLEAGUES THAT WE HAVE
IN COMMON HERE SO SHE'S ON
MULTIPLE OF THESE PROJECTS SHE'S
AT UC SANTA CRUZ.
AND YOU KNOW PART OF THAT IS
AGAIN TO LOOK AT THE. BIOLOGICAL
SIGNALS.
AS WELL AS A DOCTOR STOCK WHICH
BROUGHT UP EARLIER WE ACTUALLY
CAN'T JUST MONITOR THE CHEMISTRY
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE
BIOLOGICAL RESPONSE TO THOSE
THOSE CHEMICAL CHANGES.
BUT I ALSO THINK THERE ARE SOME
FUNDAMENTAL.
.
DECISIONS THAT COULD BE MAN MADE
ABOUT THE MANAGEMENT OF
SUSTAINABLE AQUACULTURE AND
SEAGRASSES TOGETHER WITH IN AN
ACTUARY. IF WE KNEW HOW THOSE
SEAGRASSES WERE IMPACTING.
ORGANISMS THAT FORMER SHELLS SO.
IN ADDITION TO THE BIGGER
PICTURE INTERESTS OF THE STATE
IF FOR THINKING ABOUT THE
INTERESTS OF SUBSTANTIVE
AQUACULTURE IT'S ACTUALLY
IMPORTANT TO KNOW. WHETHER OR
NOT BEING INSIDE OF THE SEA
GRASS MEADOW OR ON THE EDGE OF
THE SEA GRASS MEADOW OR RIGHT
OUTSIDE THE SEA GRASS MEADOW. IS
THE OPTIMAL PLACE FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF AN OYSTER.
OKAY.
YEAH THAT'S IN AND THAT'S WHY
ALL THESE COLLABORATIONS I THINK
A REALLY IMPORTANT AND IF WE CAN
TAKE.
IN.
BUT A PRODUCTIVE USE OF SOME OF
THESE SYSTEMS THROUGH
SUSTAINABLE AQUACULTURE AS WELL
AS HELP TO CHANGE THE SYSTEM SO
THAT THEY ACTUALLY FUNCTION
BETTER. AS OUR CLIMATE CHANGES
AND OBVIOUSLY PARTY ANSWER ALL
THIS STUFF IS TO.
MITIGATE REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
CARBON WITH PUTTING THE
ATMOSPHERE THAT THAT GETS
ABSORBED. BUT WERE.
GETTING KIND OF PASS THAT AND WE
NOW NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPLICATIONS AND BE ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT.
WHAT WE DO? AND AND WHAT'S NEXT
AND THAT'S WHY THIS IS ALL VERY
FOUNDATIONAL AND.
AND REALLY IMPORTANT.
SO MOST OF IT.
WELL ABOVE MY HEAD BUT THANK YOU
FOR.
BEING HERE PRESENTING AND
HELPING US TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
SO NEXT UP I WOULD TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
ON ANY OF THIS.
ALRIGHT.
SEEING NONE I'M GOING TO WRAP UP
AND TO GO BACK TO WHERE I
STARTED WHAT WE DO WHAT'S MY
NEXT BELT.
OR ANYBODY HERE. ALTHOUGH
SOMETIMES IT'S WE DO OUR BEST
WORK BY TAKING A DEEP BREATH.
ALLOWING SCIENCE TO DO ITS WORK
AND THEN FIGURING OUT WHAT OUR
NEXT STEPS ARE IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE INDUSTRY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION WITH THE
SCIENTISTS WHO ARE OUT THERE.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT I'M HOPING WE
GET OUT OF THIS IS IS A
BEGINNING.
THERE'S A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF WHERE WE NEED TO GO AND THEN
AS WE SEEK SOLUTIONS WEATHERS
RESTORING KELP BEDS.
DEVELOPING AQUACULTURE TARGETING
DEVELOPMENTS WERE TARGETING
RESTORATIONS AND AND THINGS IT
THAT THAT IS IS WHAT I THINK IS
ULTIMATELY.
BENEFICIAL SO APPRECIATE YOU ALL
BEING HERE TODAY VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT THE CONVERSATION
AND THAT THE INPUT INTO OUR
PROCESSESHERE. THIS I HOPE WILL
BE BY NOW IT'S GONNA BE AN
ONGOING CONVERSATION BECAUSE I
KNOW YOU'RE ALL WORKING ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. BUT IF THERE ARE
AND FOR ANYONE WATCHING ANYONE
ENGAGED IN THIS IF THERE ARE
BETTER WAYS THAT WE.
AS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ADMINISTRATION AS AS GOVERNMENTS
FOR CALIFORNIA CAN AND SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT THESE ISSUES STEPS WE
SHOULD BE TAKING HOW WE CAN BE
SMARTER. ABOUT BRINGING
FACILITATING ALL THESE
COLLABORATIONS AND
YES WE NEED TO BE FUNDING SOME
OF THIS NO THAT THAT'S AN
INHERENT QUESTION IN ALL OF
THIS.
AND ENSURING BECAUSE THOSE ARE
INVESTMENTS REALLY IN OUR FUTURE
AND IN OUR FUTURE ABILITY TO
MANAGE WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
GREAT PANELS GREAT INFORMATION.
AND MOST THIS INFORMATION I
THINK WE'LL BE ABLE TO PUT UP ON
THE.
SELECT COMMITTEES WEBSITE SO
THAT IT WILL BE OUT THERE WE
WILL HAVE A VIDEO RECORDING OF
THIS THAT WE CAN THEN LOOK AT
REFER BACK TO. WHEN WE ARE
TAKING NEXT STEP SO.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT.
ALRIGHT WE'RE ADJOURNED